Hey guys, I've fucked up a little bit.
You guys don't hear it right now, but I'm actually on a call at the moment.
Okay, so I didn't realize when they said play test, it's predetermined.
Okay, sorry, I need to listen to this.
I don't know if I'm allowed to let you guys hear this right now.
Okay, they're talking about the play test right now, and I don't know if you guys are supposed to hear this, so I muted it.
I fucked up a little bit.
I didn't even do the tutorial!
I am so fucked!
I don't know if you guys are supposed to listen on.
It's an FPS... they're saying it's an FPS game.
And that's complicated.
I don't know if I'm supposed to say that.
It is not an extraction shooter, apparently.
Oh, thank god I didn't let you guys listen to this.
It's capture the flag.
It's a capture the flag game.
Oh
my god, they're watching my stream!
Oh, okay, you guys can hear it, by the way.
Okay, they were listening on my stream, and they were like, Hey, Doki on her stream was asking if you could, if we could, like, stream this part.
Alright, you guys can hear this.
I don't think anybody else has, so NDAs, there's nothing you can do.
No one wants to talk about this game as freely as you want.
But, back to it.
We're not an extraction shooter.
We're not an exfil.
It's not like DMZ or Tarkov where you go in, pick shit up...
That's not good for me.
All you need to do is go into the match.
You all start the same.
You all have unique weapons.
You all have the same exact weapon.
By the way, guys, I'm muted, so they should have heard me say this.
And you go in, capture a biocore, defend it from everybody else who wants to steal it from you, and then get the hell out.
That's about it.
The tutorial should have kind of walked you through a couple of things.
I didn't do the tutorial, guys.
The devs that's listening to this, I didn't do the tutorial.
I didn't realize it was teams.
Like, I've been replaying with other players in this grid.
My biggest recommendation here is don't just WP the fuck out of there and go straight to the objective.
Pick a little bit of time to smell the roses.
Kill some snails.
Break their shells.
I didn't realize we're starting exactly at six, guys.
I thought I had some time.
I thought I had time.
So you do have respawns in here, guys.
So it's not a one and done.
We're not a battle royale.
You do respawn with three lives.
So you can find more around the map.
You get them as you find biocores as well.
But other than that, that's all I'm going to yap about.
Those are my two hints.
You're going to be assigned some players who are going to be community members with us.
So they've been playing for roughly about a year now.
They've seen the game in many stages.
And they know exactly how to kind of lead you in the right direction.
It's improv.
We're going to bring those people in here right now.
We're going in raw with reactions.
Thank you.
And what we're going to do is we're going to assign you some of these players that you're going to be on their team.
So some of them are little shy guys, you know, little silly guys.
They may not be able to chat and yap like I can.
But again, just follow their lead.
Ask them questions.
They'll be happy to help you out.
Now, questions by chance from anybody here that has not played.
Guys, I don't have questions, right?
We're just going to figure it out as we go along.
I'm currently going through a tutorial right now.
Oh, thank God.
It's not me.
But I won't admit it.
Are you okay?
Yes.
Just dealing with the children.
I won't admit it in a room full of people.
I'll tell it to you guys.
Which is more than the room full of people that's in this room.
It's totally fine.
I'm sure we'll have some throughout gameplay.
I'm okay telling you guys I didn't do the tutorial because you guys know me.
So I'm going to start assigning some things here.
But before I do that, admit that you're going through the tutorial right now.
Who here is still going through the tutorial and has not completed the tutorial?
I haven't done the tutorial yet.
I'm in the middle of it.
I'm reading Power right now.
Okay, I said it.
I said it.
It's me.
I raised my hand.
That's fair.
Are you completed with the tutorial as well?
Or are you still going through it?
Yeah, I'm completing the tutorial.
I'm just waiting in the main menu or lobby, I guess you'd say.
Cash money.
All right, cool.
So we're going to give it a little bit of time for everyone to complete the tutorial.
I didn't do the homework.
In the meantime...
My dog ate my homework.
There's going to be like a weird awkward pause here.
I wasn't the only one.
The other guy admitted it too.
So I'm going to give it a little bit of time for everyone to complete the tutorial.
I don't need questions, but I'm like anticipating them.
So you don't have to have questions, but I won't be hurt if you don't.
I will ask a question to just since it seems like you are eager about questions is were you guys inspired by Vanilla Psycho at all by any chance?
The fuck is that?
We have a lot of people on the team who were inspired by Psycho.
If anything, you'll see a lot of things in inspiration from mini games.
Such as Psycho, such as Hunt Showdown.
I know that!
I don't know Hunt Showdown.
The fuck is Vanilla Psycho?
The Psycho!
Oh!
I played that!
I was like Vanilla Psycho?
Is that a rap song?
The goal isn't to W key and get kills.
Winning is acquiring...
Didn't he shut down?
Oh, I shouldn't say that.
I shouldn't say that.
Have you ever...
Have you ever watched or played Vanilla the Psycho?
I know that the Psycho Frontiers was the one that was similar to Tarkov.
But I don't know how many people actually know about Vanilla Psycho before it turned into...
The fuck?
There's more than one?
Man, let me tell you...
Am I supposed to do a tutorial while they're doing Q&A?
I don't know what my place is.
So a lot of people...
A lot of people are definitely inspired by...
Am I supposed to do the tutorial while they're doing a Q&A?
Oh, shit!
Okay, guys, I'm gonna do the tutorial.
Guys, okay, we're...
I'm sorry, we're going straight...
I can't even play the tutorial!
As you said, the objective isn't to W key people, it's to kill people.
Every part of Vanilla Psycho was that.
I don't... I can't...
I was really only to halt them from doing their PvE missions.
Because you could be a PvE god and win every match.
Wait, let me...
Maybe if I reboot it, maybe...
Maybe if I reboot the game, maybe...
Maybe it's me, I'm the problem.
I'm just gonna assume I'm the problem.
How did he get in the tutorial?
How did he...
It's not that we cater to that specific side of players, it's just...
That's where the core audience...
How did they get in the tutorial?
And I didn't!
Not make it just a PvPvE.
Right.
We still have the PvE in there.
Okay.
You're going to see cool bosses in there.
Don't worry, everything is okay, guys.
Don't worry.
They're in there, but it's not the cool...
Everything is...
Alienware?
Oh, Alienware sponsored this.
...PvE related as well.
From the numerous NPCs you see around here.
Okay.
Maybe I got access while I was...
Oh, there it is!
I...
What?
Okay.
Um...
Hey!
In the middle of the tutorial?
Yes.
I can't seem to get into the tutorial since I don't have access.
You don't have...
Let me see here.
All right.
Are you...
You're streaming right now.
Yeah.
Did you put in the beta branch code into the Steam properties?
I was not given that.
I just got a...
I can send it to you now.
I just got a code...
A key, and then that was all I got.
That's all I got for the game.
Okay.
It wasn't me.
Tell me.
Yeah.
I did my job.
I provided everything.
I literally got a code from...
Just kidding.
No, no.
It's just things happen.
I got a code from somebody, and then they...
The way that y'all had access to the game was like...
That was it.
It wasn't my fault.
What the fuck is all this?
So, totally understand if it was a little bit confusing.
Or if you just didn't...
Oh.
I do have another question.
How did you guys go about...
There's a branch key?
...selecting content creators?
Okay.
Full transparency.
We go through a lot of creators that we can't select.
So...
How do I...
And also...
What do I do?
...look through...
I think it was, what?
Steam charts as well?
I don't get a message.
Streamer charts.
Where's the message?
There is a lot of people that we can't select.
And there's a lot of people that we just kind of look at what kind of games that they're playing and send them an invite on the off chance that they're interested.
That's awesome.
I think...
Full transparency.
Again, people have done that where they've never heard of us.
And to be quite frankly, there's people we've never heard of that we're happy to meet in a scenario like this.
We do these...
Right.
I want to say every single week.
Where is it?
Fridays and Saturdays.
Today is a little bit of a day.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I got added.
I was like...
Where is it?
Where do I put this?
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Yes.
Opt into...
Oh, there you go.
I'm in.
Now to update the game.
9.87 gigabytes?
Guys...
But I was always interested in knowing...
This is going to cut in and out, guys.
This is going to cut in and out.
There's an endless number of...
9.87?
I wonder if it's like a range.
Guys, the stream might buffer, maybe.
The stream might buffer.
No.
Are you guys scouting it?
Guys, the stream is going to...
No, no.
I'm going to...
The stream and Discord might buffer.
That's what some of our employees are designed to do.
That's what I did for a solid year.
I worked...
All right.
Don't worry.
It's going in.
We're at three gigabytes.
We're at...
Yeah.
We're at three gigabytes.
What do we have?
We're gonna piece this together.
We're gonna... You guys helped me piece together this conversation.
We pooled a list of creators.
We looked at the game they played.
Depending on where we are at with the development.
It's a puzzle, isn't it?
It's a puzzle right now.
It would specifically resonate with us.
Right.
And you know, both of us are gonna be game after this.
We want to be able to...
For those who don't know what the fuck is going on.
I got invited to a playtest.
Somebody messaged me asking if I want to do the playtest.
And I was like, sure.
And they're like, oh they just want to see how you vibe.
And then maybe there's more opportunities in the future.
And I was like, yeah sure.
I don't mind.
And then I just was given a key and that was it.
And I was like, join the discord and here's the key.
And I was like, cool.
Sweet.
I didn't realize there was more.
There was more to this playtest.
I didn't realize how in-depth the playtest was.
I thought I'd just show up and stream it.
Instructors were definitely unclear.
Anyway, have you guys pieced this conversation together?
Because I have no idea what's going on.
I'm trying to fucking get the game to work.
I didn't do my homework.
Hello fellow playtesters.
I did not do my homework.
I'm just here.
That's one thing that we're doing.
And in the past we've also done, what do you call it?
Immortalization projects as well.
Instruction unclear.
Downloading the game again.
Firing range area.
Above there's this digital chandelier.
I'm worried I'm going to miss out on information.
And those are creators who have worked with us in the past.
Have developed content for us.
Will this be on the quiz teacher?
To make it better.
By the way, this is capture the flag.
For those who don't know.
This is not an extraction shooter.
I was like, oh, it looks like an extraction shooter.
But it's actually capture the flag.
I'm part of the group project.
Really?
We're all assigned in the teams.
I.e.
group projects.
And we're supposed to talk to each other too.
In the teams.
I thought it was like, you know.
You know, like randoms and stuff.
Like, you know, in other playtests.
You play with other randoms.
But you don't really talk to them.
But we're supposed to divide each other.
Into groups.
And then...
And also just really created cool...
And then like play with the team.
And play against each other.
And then we're flunking.
We are so...
I'm so sorry.
I hope there's like the two other...
By the way, teams of three.
I really hope the other team...
My other team members is going to carry me.
Because I have no idea what the fuck is going on.
So we got stuff like this.
I get this question a lot.
There's a...
I don't even know.
What kind of questions are you asking?
People have been asking me.
Is this live?
It's not.
It would be really cool if it was.
Apparently I'm patching 33 guild fights.
But we're at 33 now.
I haven't really asked about what this TV is going to do in the future.
But somebody suggested, hey, can I just stream in here?
And I was like, why not?
And then somebody said, well, what if it automatically like pulls somebody who's just trolling and puts like...
That's me.
Bad things on their stream and says...
That's not me.
But no.
More stuff like this.
This weekend, we do have a brand new version of this to bring players in.
And our community is going to test for us.
Because that's not me.
He meant really bad things.
Not the bad things.
And right above the dance floor, we have a very special room.
And I can't say anything.
We haven't announced it yet.
But we have a very special room.
It's going to come up right over here.
And we just looked at it today and it looks sick.
Here we're dancing.
It's even further up above.
But that's where it goes.
Also, this snail hologram has boobs.
I don't know if anyone's interested in looking.
Oh, I turned nudity off, guys.
There's apparently...
Now I know why.
I see.
There's a nudity function in the game.
And I was like, why is there a nudity function?
Let me turn that off.
That's crazy.
Snitties?
Snitties is crazy.
Like the sensor.
I turned it off.
I turned it off, the sensor.
Snitties is wild, bro.
That's crazy.
So, like, I don't know what it's going to be, but...
No, that's actually not...
I know.
We'll see.
There was talks about putting a sneener on it, but I think...
What?
Wow.
Okay.
See, here it is.
Show nudity.
You know, being inclusive, I support it.
Sneetie.
He's in sneener.
Oh.
Why am I lagging?
Be careful.
Whoa.
Why am I lagging?
There is a nudity option, actually, in the game.
What?
Oh, yeah.
I was like, what happened?
What happened?
If you watch it...
You can.
Just watch it.
Let's go straight to the...
Because I showed the options?
Okay.
Let's go in.
Maybe I can go in now.
Turn off the camera customization, and from there, you'll be able to...
I'll turn the discreet a little bit quiet.
You guys don't need to listen to this.
If you only knew the power of the Biocore, he'd be on our...
Is this tutorial?
Oh, there's me.
Oh, this is, like, retro.
If you only knew the power of the...
Now, remember the plan.
Oh my god.
I look like Sylvester Stallone right now.
Except with 80's hair.
Body scar?
That's right.
That's me!
No, it's not Doki Bird.
It says show nudity.
Wait.
Oh god.
I'm not... I don't want to... I'm worried.
I'm...
Wait, if I...
Oh thank god.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
Can I technically take it off?
Like...
I don't... where does the... cause it says show nudity.
Like where... where does it show?
Like where does it...
Maybe it's the boobs.
Maybe...
Maybe it's like...
Maybe it's the... for the girl.
Okay, we're definitely not going to do it for...
I... I was curious.
I was curious.
Okay.
Like... I was like wondering where that part... where the nudity part shows.
So I... I was curious.
But now I'm like no, that's a bad idea.
That's actually...
I stopped myself before it's too late.
I realized it was a very bad idea, guys.
I...
I realized it was a very bad idea.
Okay, let's see.
I turned down the Discord cause you guys don't have to hear.
Actually...
Okay.
Did he just fucking say 55 runs?
This is my first game.
And we also have minigames.
There's minigames?
Um...
Wait.
We did a test to see how much...
Oh...
would handle performance-wise.
And it was okay.
It could be better, but...
Okay, nice.
I gotta show the abs.
If not Doki Bird worked out so hard, I gotta show the assets.
Right now, it's set to 21.
Yeah, that seems right.
But we can do any number that we want to.
I think...
Oh, I have a flat ass.
This sucks.
Wait, none?
Just some more optimization.
Dude, why was there...
Definitely CPS.
Okay.
I gotta show...
I got it.
If this...
If this showed more ass, I would pick this, because it hugs the body.
But, like, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't...
It doesn't matter.
Ooh.
Okay.
This way.
Alright.
Grab your gear, folks.
I know what you are.
Let's hit the battlefield and make this place totally ours.
Stoked to get started.
Yes.
Look at...
Do you have a good...
This is...
Yes.
This way.
Let's keep walking this shit, dude.
Okay.
We did it.
I think he perfectly reflects voice number three.
I think...
I think he definitely...
Let's go, bro!
Let's go!
Okay.
Makeup and face paint?
Oh, shit.
Alright.
You don't see the eyes though.
Let's see.
No, no tattoo.
Alright.
We are good.
Let's go.
Finish.
I'm pretty sure Dokie is going through the tutorial.
Is everybody still going through the tutorial?
I got called out.
I don't know if you guys heard that.
Yeah, that's me.
No, you're not supposed...
What?
Was it an error message?
Yeah, we're going through tutorial, guys!
We're going through tutorial!
Guys, I'm gonna turn down the Discord.
I don't want you guys...
to hear them call me out even more.
I'm gonna mute the Discord.
Look, I already got called out!
Oh, nice!
I've just been using the cafeteria.
Now, there are other shades with other less good-looking fucking douchebags living in there.
It's okay, they're still doing the Q&A!
Okay, I'll turn up the game audio.
...competing over them to stay alive.
So, before you were frozen, you may have been a dental hygienist, or an accountant, or a vegetarian, but now you're a fighter.
Because that's what we need.
So get used to running, shooting, and getting shot in the face, because that's what you're gonna be doing for the majority of your time.
I recommend you get shot with...
Sorry, I'm listening.
Hopefully, this has helped.
If not, I don't care.
Guys, maybe I should skip the tutorial, guys!
Maybe I should
skip the tutorial!
...
Alright, we're gonna speedrun!
We're gonna speedrun this!
We're gonna speedrun!
I raised up the volume!
I hope it's okay!
No, I won't say they're waiting on me!
But, like, I'm speedrunning!
No!
...
Alright, let's go, let's go, let's go!
Why isn't it going faster?!
I'm literally waiting at an elevator!
Oh my god!
This is elevator simulator!
I don't understand!
Please, I need...
...
I'm trying!
I'm in a fucking cutscene!
Okay, where the fuck...
Who do I talk to?
Okay...
Yeah, that's me!
Yeah, let's go!
Mission complete!
Wait, is...
Are these real people?
Did I do it?
Oh, now I do the tutorial!
What if I just don't?
...
Guys, we'll figure out the lore at another time!
Okay, now we're in the tutorial!
Now!
...
I thought we were!
Apparently this is a tutorial!
...
This is what all the fuss is over.
The goal?
Find and secure as many Biocores as you can.
There are three of them out there creatively named Biocore A, B, and C.
Whichever team gets the most, wins.
You'll always find them somewhere in the center of the map, but the locations change every match.
Nothing you can't handle.
Probably.
Okay.
You can start each match in your base vehicle.
Bring any Biocores.
I can do that.
Alright, here we go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Oh wait, do I have to kill these?
Okay, these don't matter.
Go, go, go, go, go!
The dead yard is a barren area, separating the shade from the... Go, go, go, go!
We're going so fast!
We have to do our homework five minutes before classes start!
Let's head upstairs and activate the Biocore scanner and find out where they are.
Okay.
Activate system.
The Biocore scanner will show you where the Biocore is known by...
Okay.
This is scanner!
If you get killed, you can respawn.
Okay!
We have three lives!
Gotcha!
When you're out there for reals, fighting for a Biocore with your standard issued peashooter could be an uphill battle.
So let's get you some better gear.
But in order to buy anything, first you need to get some power.
Okay.
So let's get murdering.
Get the Biocore!
Alright.
Take the loot!
You can't get gear without power.
And you can't get power without... Okay.
Oh my god, why is it taking so long to kill these guys?
...practice looting by mercilessly killing these cardboard cutouts we've conveniently left free.
Alright, that should be enough power for a gun and a shield.
So now it's time to go shopping.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Okay, shopping time!
You can use the power to buy gear.
Any weapons you buy will stay with you for the rest to locate the shop.
Okay, shop.
Alright, buy!
Shield!
What did I buy?
Oh my god!
...
I was like, what the fuck did I buy?
Okay, it's okay.
We got a gun.
I'm trying my best!
...
I'm speedrunning so hard!
Hey!
Okay, Biocores are usually fine to take the biocore.
First you need to interact.
First you stabilize this.
Okay, interact!
Okay, there you go.
Okay, we gotta lower the...
That's okay.
I can lower the sound effect while I do this.
Okay, there you go.
...
I have waiting time.
I'm trying my best!
Boom!
Alright.
Okay, I have special abilities!
Use a biocore!
Alright, watch this!
Speedrun!
Okay, sorry, that...
Now!
Speedrun starts now!
...
Wait!
Wait fast!
...
I am pinging!
Please!
This is a speedrun!
...
Oh my god!
I need to be taught how to revive!
Oh my god, look at me!
...
Alright.
Get the biocore.
I'm running!
I'm running as fast as I can!
Oh, I can slide!
Oh my god, what the fuck is going on in my name?
Okay, there you go.
Alright, as you cross, the biocore will alert them to your position.
Oh yeah?
Watch this.
Okay, give me a sec.
Sorry, I'm a little nervous.
...
No!
Okay, there you go, go, go, go.
We don't need to learn how...
They were telling me to ping, and I was like no.
...
To secure the put in the machine.
They're like, Doki ping!
Ping Doki!
And I'm like, no!
My teammates don't need to know what's happening!
...
Oh, I have to defend!
Okay.
That's fine.
...
Get too close?
Okay.
Wait.
They're not even gonna move closer to me.
Where's the wrist?
Oh my god, this gun is weak as hell.
Holy shit.
Okay, I should have kept the shotgun.
... Nice.
We did it.
That was so easy.
Yeah, why would the enemies need to know where they are?
They're gonna be dead anyway.
...
My team doesn't need to know where they are.
One of the devs was like, please ping.
...
They're like, Doki ping, please.
We did it!
...
I don't trust where it comes from, I really want to play it off.
That was a good gel for you two there.
...
Oh, can you?
That's pretty dope.
Okay, I mean it.
...
Oh, I'm...
It's not just me!
Somebody's having issues!
I'm not last!
Oh my god, it's not just me!
Let's fucking go!
Alright, now I'll listen to you.
Let's go!
I'm gonna switch my shirt out real quick and I'll be right back.
Not last!
I didn't even do my homework and at least I showed up!
Hex Blaster.
Alright, I'm gonna switch to the Hex Blaster.
It's up to you.
And now you're done with the...
Don't forget about the gear.
When you get there, I want you to locate a shop and buy yourself a shield.
3 minutes or 1 minute?
3 minutes.
What do you mean step 2 out of 8?!
There was more?!
Step 2?!
Alright, so Doki's done.
I'm done!
He said I'm done!
So like right now, as I speak.
No way.
Press play.
It shouldn't take this long.
It should be literally less than 10 seconds.
Alright, I'm gonna get the shotgun.
I feel like...
What about the sniper?
I wanna try the sniper.
Is this test?
Alright, I'm in the test now.
No Doki!
Don't kill him!
Cancel Q!
Cancel!
Okay!
Damn it.
He got me.
I canceled.
I did it.
Alright, let's see.
I need to lower my sense.
It's way too high.
Alright, so let me at least get this game ready.
Graham, if it's not giving you any luck here, we can have somebody trying to help you out with...
I'm like bringing...
I'm like the...
There's a group of friends.
And then one of the friends was like, Hey, can my little sister come and join us?
No, no.
It's entirely up to you.
The reason why I ask is because it might require a PC restart.
That's me.
Yeah, yeah.
Just give it a quick restart.
And I'm gonna get people into it when you come back.
Hopefully, you should be able to get in the game.
Try that out.
And then when you come back, I'll let you know when you're on.
That's me.
If not, we'll have somebody help out.
Okay?
Thank you.
Yeah, for sure.
Alrighty, so...
What we're gonna do now is finally hopefully play the game.
So, I'm gonna announce teams who are gonna be competing with each other.
And all you have to do to accept the team invite is press Y on your keyboard.
Okay.
And if you're Latino like me, you press E.
What?
You guys have different keyboards?
So...
Team 1 is gonna be myself, Doki, and Iko.
So, I'm gonna send y'all guys some invites here.
And then Team 2 is gonna be...
Iceman.
Five stars.
Is it stars?
Yeah.
Okay.
Five stars.
Iceman, invite five stars and Kubaki.
Mm-hmm.
Winton, invite Catboy and Dasbear.
Froggy, invite Calus.
Oh, I just pronounced E.
Oh, I thought you guys just had different keyboards.
But if you can't get Grim in, we might have to put Kusai in there for you until...
For the time being.
All right.
So...
Whee!
I just did an invite to Iko.
My bad.
Guys, we're gonna be inviting Grim.
We're so fucked.
Wait.
We're not ready.
Is there gonna be like a stream mode for the music?
We're not gonna be pinging anything.
There is a stream mode right now.
Wow!
Wait, can I get back up?
All right.
I'm watching Doki's chat tell her the best why.
Oh!
It's giving me so much energy right now.
I thought you guys were teaching me how to say...
I thought you guys were just teaching me how to say, like, let's go.
Why in Spanish?
So, I'm just gonna wait for Grim to come in real quick.
I thought you guys were teaching me how to say why in Spanish.
But once we get the combinations in, we're gonna all press Y to queue up.
And I'll give the announcement for that.
All righty.
I'm back.
It's okay.
We're okay, guys.
Hey, if I'm ready up, it's fine.
Actually, I also just noticed...
Because I need to wait for two other people.
Okay.
I'm back.
Deep voice guy.
So, it doesn't matter.
Because you guys are teaching me how to say Y.
I'm a resident announcer.
There we go.
And why?
I was like, wait, are these real people?
No, they're not.
So, who was the last team?
If Grim can't get in, just invite Metzu.
Froggy.
Yeah!
Not last!
I showed up, even though I didn't do my homework.
I showed up.
Guys, they're play testing for people like me.
They're playing testing for people like you.
I'm just kidding.
I am the regular player.
If they Doki proof this, this game will be solid.
Not right.
You gotta lock in.
Guys, I have a sniper.
I'm so locked in.
I don't know how good people are at FPS games in this lobby.
So, like...
Why do you want me to look at your ass so badly?
I might be fucked.
Hold still.
Nice test.
Dude, you're so oily, bro.
What the fuck is...
What is with your pants, dude?
It looks like there's a hole in it.
This is a test.
Dude, did you put a hole on your b-hole, dude?
What?
You put a black little dot on his b-hole on his underwear.
Bro, this is one of the developers, guys.
Yeah, you can ready up right now.
Your team lead will queue the search for the match once we're all ready.
All right, sounds good.
What's going on?
I'm doing the best I can.
Yeah.
My best.
That's what's going on.
We're just waiting.
We're waiting for some guy that didn't show up.
And that's why we haven't started the game in 38 minutes.
Because of that one guy.
What I just said y'all did not hear, right?
In Discord?
Nope, didn't hear anything.
Sweet!
Yeah, that one guy that we're waiting for right now.
I didn't say anything amazing.
I just wanted to see if y'all could hear me.
Uh, Grim, what's up?
Hey, what's up?
I'm back.
Alright, awesome.
I don't even know.
I think he never showed up.
Yeah.
Can't believe it.
We couldn't start the lobby because of him.
Not because of me.
You don't like chicken.
Nah, just any type of chicken.
It's okay not to like chicken.
I don't already do any.
Where's my melee?
He needed to save you.
Yeah.
I remember back in the day I used to get excited.
I think you're nice.
Guys, I can't be like...
Guys, I can't be illiterate.
If I was illiterate, why do I have glasses?
If I was illiterate, how could I have glasses on?
I feel like it just sits in the skin.
And the meat is always just whack.
Exactly.
I can't be illiterate.
Yeah, but that's like all of them.
Oh yeah, did I bring down... I already brought down the sound effects.
Is Discord okay too?
Shut up, Echo.
Who asked?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you guys are all so mean to me.
We are back.
It's like the pineapple.
We're still waiting.
Alright, so because I did not account for Metsu rizzing me up, I have to put him on a team here.
So...
Wynton, can you actually...
Catboy actually...
How did he get that?
Sorry man, I'm kicking you out.
Oh!
Wait, which sniper did I get?
Is it a battle rifle?
Oh, there it is.
Look at the Rizzlord.
Which one did I get?
I assume these are all... this is default.
Do what you can do here.
Okay.
Did I say Metsu?
No, this is way too slow.
I'm borderline dyslexic.
This is way... the sentence is way too slow.
Okay, here we go.
Oh shit.
You mean to tell me you got that dyslexic Rizz?
Oh, hey.
I need to make sure the...
Bro...
I need to make sure...
You don't know what it is, do you?
No, not yet.
I'm suffering over here.
Okay.
Alright, so for the sake of getting through this man, I don't want to waste your time on it.
Let's get somebody to help you out.
So, in this case, we're going to swap you out.
No.
And I don't know who you're supposed to be with again, my bad.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, Kuzai.
Yeah, yeah, just in fact, Kuzai.
And we're gonna get started...
Okay.
I'm just making sure I understand the sniper.
So, let me just be like, everybody can now start reining up.
So, everybody can be like, everybody can now start reining up.
Press free to draw.
And then we're gonna start searching for the match.
As far as...
Who's gonna be helping you, let me see here.
Oh, we're in!
Oh, searching.
Guys, we went straight into...
I was gonna give you guys life updates, but like, we went straight into this.
We went straight into this.
I was right into this.
We had no intro, we were just doing it live.
See why not?
There we go.
Oh, match found!
Alright, so.
Okay.
What's gonna happen is, whenever you load into the game after the little animation you have with the cool car driving everywhere, you're gonna see on the bottom left corner of your monitor what team you are on.
It's gonna say team 1, 2, 3, or 4.
You're gonna join the Discord BC right below us here in this server.
Just join the matching team that you have.
Doki, you do not do that.
We stay up here.
I work here.
I refuse to move.
Yay!
I have HeadDev!
Wait!
We can't lose!
He can literally cheat!
Guys!
My Dev can literally put in a cheat code and make sure I don't lose.
Is it just Ascendant?
Yes, Ascendant.com.
Okay.
I get HeadDev!
Okay, I see.
The Dev's my favorite!
I'm the little sister!
Special treatment!
Let's go!
Slash... Slash God mode.
Catboy.
Okay, what do I have?
I have Seer.
I have a little bit of Troubleshooting.
What do I have?
I only have one thing.
I'm broke.
I have Finite.
I can try, but...
Okay.
Perks are passive.
I have none.
I don't have any problems with the game.
But Grim likes stuff nice.
Grim, my recommendation is to try and change your graphic settings in the game.
Let's go!
Okay.
Try that out and see if it gets you in.
Alright.
What's happening?
Why is this gun so fucking weak?
Holy shit!
That gun is so weak!
Oh my god!
I have a sniper!
Where's my cheat code to make you buff my sniper?
Okey dokey!
You there?
Yo!
Are we gaming?
Am I talking in game?
Wait!
My in-game voice chat doesn't work!
No!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Let's go to Doki real quick.
No!
Okay.
Wait.
Now...
Don't hit that tree.
Wait.
Let me...
I need to push the talk, guys.
I need...
Give me a sec.
I need to push the talk on Discord.
Why are you inside, Doki?
Hello?
Don't say that.
I hope that God heard chat and I knew that.
That was fucking awful.
What do we...
What do we do?
Why is my sniper gun so bad?
What do you mean it's so bad?
Explain.
Give me context.
Why is the damage so weak?
Can you buff the damage on the sniper gun?
Okay.
No, no, no.
All right.
No.
Okay.
So come here.
Come here.
All right.
So we're gonna...
We're gonna run into some smart stuff.
All right.
See this little gun in my hand?
Yeah.
A little pistol that I got?
This is a...
Get out of here, chat!
Sorry.
This is a...
Oh.
Press your three key.
You're gonna get a pistol out.
Yeah.
And this is gonna have unlimited ammo.
This is like your utility to kill everything that is not...
Wait.
Is this the strongest gun?
No.
Oh.
It's just the strongest gun against...
The mobs?
Yeah.
The mobs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Wait.
I have limited ammo?
Yeah.
You have limited ammo with the pistol.
But not your sniper.
You don't have unlimited ammo with your sniper.
Okay.
All right.
So, see that snail?
Go murder it.
Okay.
Murder it faster.
There you go.
Nice.
All right.
So, whenever you kill these things, don't run over it yet.
It's gonna drop stuff.
All right?
See?
Heal stuff.
Okay.
We're gonna watch the snails drop stuff.
All right.
So...
Oh, okay.
Let me see here.
Where's the snail?
Fix your game, ascendant.
Where's your snails at?
Okay.
Here's one right here.
Let me kill it real quick.
All right.
So, you drop stuff.
You see this little green thing right here?
Yeah.
Over here.
That's the power.
We need to get as much of that as we can for maybe two minutes while we're out here.
Okay.
All right.
So, the more we have this, the more we'll be able to use it to buy gear and stuff.
Oh, you can take that.
You can take that right there.
It's a purple shield that you can have.
Oh, nice.
All right.
So, big.
We've got 90, 50, 60, eco.
What's the math?
Hurry up, Jarvis.
200.
Thank you.
All right.
So, we have 200 power.
We're gonna go all...
We're gonna go...
We're all gonna leave the scales alone now.
Okay.
And we're gonna go right over here to scan for the objective.
This is the objective, but you need to scan for more objectives.
Okay.
It's confusing.
I know.
It's crazy.
Where's the other teams?
They're doing the same exact thing we are right now, which is...
Oh, but they're on other sides of the maps, right?
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, this is our forward base.
This is where we're gonna respawn when we die.
Okay.
So, you can respawn...
We have to go to A.
Yeah, yeah.
We're gonna go to A.
And then we found A again using A.
Oh, A.
What?
That's what it is.
Oh, dude, we got super lucky.
It's like right in front of us.
Yay!
Yippee!
All right.
So, actually, we're gonna go over here really quick before we start counting down A.
Because...
We're gonna deposit all of our power.
We're gonna upgrade our weapons.
Yeah, we're gonna upgrade our weapons.
We're gonna upgrade our shields.
So, that purple shield you have, right?
Yeah.
Whenever you die...
Wait, do I have fall damage?
Nope.
You can jump off of it.
Oh, there's no fall damage?
Fuck yeah.
There's no fall damage.
Sweet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
Wait.
It's a little ouchy.
Where the fuck...
Where are they?
So, yeah.
I believe you.
Oh, my God.
Oh, really?
Can I have my hand, please?
Yeah, see?
The death advantage.
I didn't shoot my gun.
So, that purple shield that you have, if you die, you do not respawn with it.
Whoa!
Everything that you buy...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
...from...
This beautiful big machine, that will, like, everything you buy here, you will respawn with.
So, what we're gonna do, really quick, we're gonna spend some cash, but I need you to deposit your cash.
Wait.
Where do I deposit?
How do I deposit?
Right here.
Is your balance?
Yeah, yeah.
Put it all in there.
All right.
So, it should say, like, 300, almost 400 for you right now.
Now, you're gonna use that power to buy anything that you want here.
So, I would recommend buying a blue shield, but picking up your purple shield when you drop it.
Because if you die...
Why would I...
Because if you die, you don't keep the purple shield.
Oh!
Okay.
Yeah.
But since you bought this from the shop, you will respawn with it.
There you go.
All right.
Now, pick it up.
And then, I'll pick up the purple.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
And then, one last thing.
You're gonna buy this thing called a VTEC-6.
The VTEC-6?
Oh, behind...
Whoa!
There's a shield there.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
That's fine.
My bad.
No, my bad.
That's on me.
I was yapping too long.
Let me know... oh, they are pushing.
Wait, wait.
Do I have to get the hell out of here?
No, no, no.
I don't need to.
Okay.
Maybe I do.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Oh, they didn't reload!
This gun isn't reloading!
No!
So, it looks like we...
It's not that we are intentionally designed to share the shop, but because we spawn technically close together...
Yeah.
This is very...
Again, this is how the shop works.
Okay.
So, they also needed the exact same things that we do.
So...
Okay.
Let's just go to A.
Looks like somebody is at A right now.
Okay.
I can't believe...
If I...
If my shotgun was reloaded, he would have been dead.
I believe.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay.
There's two up here right now.
I just keep dying.
Just fall down.
Fall down.
I'll get you.
Okay.
They're not...
Oh, they're...
Just give us a little bit of cover.
I don't think they're gonna push.
No, they're not.
They're low.
Oh, behind us!
Something going on?
I don't think they're gonna push.
No, they're not.
Oh!
I'm coming.
I'm...
Oh, no!
I'm down.
Oh, I think...
I'm fucked, here.
I guess.
There's so many...
There's so many people here.
I'm healing ya.
I would say let's just like hold back really quick.
It might be smarter to let like these teams fight each other.
Oh, yeah.
I'm about to spawn in three seconds.
And if they wanna take A, they can.
But we can now scan for B.
I hear them above me.
Oh, they are right here.
I thought I had a shotgun earlier.
Oh, I knocked one.
How do we heal?
Yeah, yeah, eco.
Show her the gloves.
I need some energy ammo.
Here, here.
No, I don't have energy ammo.
Doki, come over here real quick.
Shit, there is someone next to me.
Oh, no, no, they are up here.
They are trying to shoot us through the fucking window.
Where are they?
We are going to come right here actually.
We are going to protect ourselves.
Oh, he got me.
Yeah, he did.
Whoa, there is people behind me.
Oh shit, there is people behind you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm like sort of safe.
Do it.
I don't know.
I'm watching, I'm watching.
Let's just fall back this way.
Oh shit, there is somebody right here in front of us.
Just run, just run, just run.
Let's go into our base.
Okay.
Let's get some safety.
Oh, up top, up top, up top.
Up top?
Oh.
How am I peeing?
I am ass dude.
Oh my god.
One down.
Alright, you got energy right there by the way.
Okay, alright.
Stay right here Doki.
Actually, press right here.
I want you to come in here and I want you to see if you can share some of your ammo.
Oh.
Share my ammo?
How do I share it?
Yeah, press tab.
Okay.
And on the right side, you are going to see like a green circle of bullets on it.
Oh.
Is it like full or anything?
Does it have a number on top of it?
Do you want me to drop this?
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Drop all of it.
I did.
Okay, cool.
So, now what Iko is going to do, she is going to use these healing gloves.
Oh.
Oh, I see.
Alright, cool.
Now, do you want to see how you can also heal by yourself if you don't have any type of heals?
Okay.
We are going to go to the snail.
Look at my shields.
I have white shields.
Don't kill them yet.
What I'm going to do, I'm going to crack the shield.
I'm going to melee it.
See how I got my shield back?
If you melee...
You melee to get shield back?
Oh, okay.
You can...
And so like, imagine a scenario where you've got a player down.
Like, an enemy player down.
Yeah.
And they're crawling.
And they're waiting to be picked up.
You can...
Instead of just thirsting them with your weapon, you can run up to them and melee the shield and get your shield back.
I see.
Shields up.
I need heavy ammo.
I'm not heavy.
Shotgun ammo.
What color is it?
Red.
You need red?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We definitely don't have that.
But we do have enough power at the shop.
Nice.
So, you can go buy some ammo.
Okay.
I got some.
No, it's okay.
Okay, guys.
We're learning.
We're getting better.
Okay.
Looks like we're...
Yeah, they're running off with A, but we can just go B instead.
So, let's just do that.
Okay.
The sniper fucking sucks, guys.
That barely does jack shit.
Do you want a tank?
Tank?
What do you mean?
It's a tank.
Oh, there's a tank?
Okay.
Yes.
Come up to the front right here and then just press E.
Oh, shit.
And press right.
I'm right-clicking.
I'm right -clicking.
I killed a snail.
I ran over a snail.
I'm right-clicking.
I don't hear the music.
I don't know if...
There it is.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, do I...
Can I run people over?
Why can't I run over a fucking tree?
If you hit left-click, too, you have a flamethrower on front.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I can't burn the tree down.
It's not worth it.
Let's see if I can get...
Oh, my God.
Please.
I need a follow-up.
Why didn't I follow the road to get anywhere?
Like, where did I drive to?
Like, where did I drive this thing to?
It's like...
You're doing...
Oh, my God.
I didn't thread the fucking needle.
There you go.
You're zooming.
Oh, my God.
Run.
This is...
My truck is too tall.
You want to...
My truck is too fucking tall.
This is bullshit.
Like, where do I fucking hide?
Just stay right there.
You're literally in the tank.
What we're gonna do, I'm gonna try and grab B and we can capture it using this tank.
Okay, okay.
What can I do?
Man, that's a big bitch thing.
Turn around.
Austin powers it.
My truck is 15 meters and this only accepts 14 meters and under.
Alright.
Man, I think you got a bigger bed than you need.
No!
I can't just force it.
Yep.
You press E, though, so you can hop back out of the tank.
Don't you dare fucking take it.
What do I do?
I'm just here.
That was dirty.
Guys, I just...
My truck is so poor.
Oh, man.
What are you gonna do?
Fucking kill me in the truck?
Get down here.
Okay, I'm still in the truck.
I would say just stay in it.
They literally cannot kill you.
Wait, they can't kill me?
Oh, sweet.
It's gonna take a fuck-ton to kill you, so that's why I would say stay in it.
But at the same time, we need to also catch up with you so that way we can...
Yeah, like, put these outside.
I think they know there's a truck in here.
Put it in reverse, Terry.
It's okay.
I'm the getaway car.
The moment you get this, we can get away.
Wait, there's people behind.
No, that's you guys.
Yeah, it's us.
Wait, why am I glitching out?
All right, here, here, here.
Let me drive.
Oh, okay.
Call me a coach.
Okay.
I don't know if you can, like, get past that.
There's, like, a meter thing over there.
Oh, my God.
I have, like...
Oh, there's a purple shield in there.
Oh, I used up all my bullets.
You were trying... Are you fucking kidding me?
There's ammo on this?
Okay, no.
I was like, there's a purple shield right here.
No, never mind.
Never mind.
It just has four shots.
What are we supposed to do?
I'm sorry.
I'm frustrated.
Okay.
It's always the staff on staff violence.
I didn't mean to yell at you.
Oh, it's a cooldown.
All right, cool.
So, we're out of here.
We want to try and use...
Wait, but I thought we were supposed to go to B.
No, no.
We are supposed to go to B.
But, like, at the same time, we can also choose to go to C.
We've got three objectives to choose from.
So, it's about, like, adapting to you.
Oh, okay.
You don't have to go to it.
You can just choose not to.
And I think it's the best to just park the car here.
But what if they steal the car?
There's no way that they will.
Okay.
I think they're gonna steal the car, guys.
I am literally Megamind right now.
I can't promise that they won't.
But I don't think that they will.
If I see a fucking tank, I'm gonna steal it.
I would 100% steal a tank.
Guys, I think we're gonna come back and then the tank is gone.
What?
Wait.
Steal bow... Oh, they're still fighting!
What the fuck is going on?
I'm so confused.
I can't climb!
You know what, Toki?
We're not gonna go that way.
We're gonna go this way.
Wait, I'm here.
We're gonna go up the ladder.
But I'm here.
You're here?
What do you mean you're here?
One right here.
Oh, in front of you!
Come here, come here, come here!
Oh my god, he's so low!
Oh, nice.
I got one down.
There's one guy on me.
But I don't know where he went.
Yeah, he has the bio cord too, so we definitely need to kill him.
Wait, how did I get damaged?
Nice,
okay.
Let's shield swap.
Wait, I'm like low HP.
I don't know how I got damaged.
Uh, here you can take this.
Oh, I picked that up by yourself.
I just picked it up.
I tried to dodge it.
What?
Ooh, ooh, oh, Toki, Toki, get this gun, get this gun right here.
This gun?
Okay.
Best gun in the game.
Oh, okay.
Hands down.
So, the way that it works, it is a multi-fire burst, but...
Yeah?
Oh, he's gonna shout at me.
Um, it is a multi-fire burst, but it does a shit ton of damage to shields.
What the fuck?
What hurt me?
It will, it will...
So, it's not that it's hurting you, there's this little thing around the map.
Um...
Yeah?
And that truck, whenever it's activated, it can turn off technology.
So it can shut doors, lock them down, and turn off, like, and shut off your shields.
Wait, oh, okay, so the enemy team did that, or is it just an event?
Yeah, an enemy team did it.
Oh, okay.
It is an event, though.
Like, it's a manual triggered event.
Yeah, shut...
Cover me, I'm reloading.
...the Bio-Core holder.
This is something we definitely want to push now, because it's the last remaining Bio-Core.
Okay.
Guys, I think they stole the truck.
There's someone behind you, there's someone behind you.
Oh.
What?
I didn't reload!
I didn't reload again!
Okay, I, I, I need to learn to reload.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's just very limited.
The ammo per shot.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
So, it's like an eight burst shot, but I'm telling you, like, once you, once you kind of, like, figure it out, like, it rips.
It's insanely good.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay.
It has, like...
No, it has, like...
Yeah, no, it has eight rounds, but it's so fast.
And if you also, uh, pull out your pistol, it will run a little bit faster, as well.
Oh, so it's, like, normal.
I might need...
Is there heals?
I'm, I'm low.
I'm HP.
Yeah, you are low.
You might have some shield repairs on you.
Do you see, like...
What?
Shield repairs?
You might have shield repairs.
Press, like, look, hold your four key, and you'll bring up the, the healing wheel.
No.
That means you ain't got shit, then.
That's nothing.
There's a sniper behind us.
Couple, couple.
Oh, shit.
I'm lefty.
I'm gonna kill this snail.
Oh, shit!
Yeah, yeah, kill the snail.
You got it.
No, no, there's a guy behind me.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm holding your hand.
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Hit!
What?
He's way over here.
I...
It's Winston.
He, he also has a midnight surge.
That's his gun.
Oh!
How do I...
Oh, respawn.
Okay.
I was like, what hit?
I died so fast!
I just wanted to punch some snails.
He's down.
Nice.
Alright, I'm rushing towards the sea right now.
Are y'all in a car?
Yeah, we're coming over.
We're figuring it out as we go along.
Oh, wait!
A tank is still here!
Wait, nobody stole the tank!
Oh, there's a tree.
What?
Don't mind me.
It's okay.
I haven't got my license.
Oh, my God.
Put it on.
Oh, yeah.
They asked if I...
If I...
If I'm in the option, you can put streamer mode on, and I feel a little wild today.
I didn't do my homework, and I'm fucking playing...
Oh, shit!
We are in the open.
I don't like that.
This is not great.
Oh, I'm okay, but I don't know for how long, because I'm very low.
Run, run, run, run.
I don't think I can run.
I'm gonna have to die here.
Oh, no way.
Oh, no way, bro.
All right.
Well, that was my last try.
I'm big dead.
You have the wrong dude to mess with.
Sniper on the prowl.
Trying to ruin my totally bitching day.
Man down.
We'll miss you out there, buddy.
No stress, Doki.
It's all you.
You win this.
Easy.
Oh, hey.
I don't think so, because...
What the fuck?
That should have been a hit.
You can easily...
No!
It's okay.
I still have a life.
You do have a life.
That should have been a hit.
You're free.
All right.
Last respawn.
Wait.
Can I...
Can I buy people back?
How do I...
You can.
How do I buy people back?
You got to go to a computer called a resurrection point, so...
Do I have the money?
You have to have power, which we did, to buy them back.
It's very much like Call of Duty.
Oh, okay.
I think I have the money.
I didn't spend anything.
Yeah, you should have the money.
But I also think that's the game.
Oh, no.
It's still being held up.
Okay, so...
No, I...
Oh, wait.
I don't.
No, that's defensive.
Wait.
What?
Where is it?
So...
I'm moving here.
There you go.
All right.
So, you have a waypoint marker.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
It's pink.
Yeah, yeah.
Get in the car and drive there.
Oh, my God.
It's 200 meters away?
Yeah, I know.
That's far.
Okay.
Also, yes.
Yes.
I thought it was like...
Wow.
Oh, God.
The camera on here sucks.
Like, yeah.
We were very aware of it.
We fixed it.
Oh, God.
I'm getting off.
I'm sorry.
No, that's fair.
That's not a very good car.
I don't blame you.
Wait.
Why is there a number five on my screen?
So, that top left corner says steal bio core.
Yeah.
That is the timer and how much longer you need to wait to...
How much time you have left to steal the bio core from somebody.
Oh, I see.
Four seconds away from capturing it.
No time for naps now, my friend.
We need to get back in the action.
Okay.
I got it.
You can tell me about heaven later.
Because now, right now...
Do we go to...
Right now.
Now, get it.
Oh, don't.
Get back here.
We're gonna go.
Okay.
Wait.
Why are we...
That's the end.
One last time.
Why are we going...
Oh, my God.
What is going on over here, dude?
Why are we going away from the bio core?
I have to go around a little bit here because driving through all that was a pain in the ass.
Oh.
We're not gonna make it.
We're...
Oh, boy.
You never know.
Never know.
We're not gonna make it.
We should go.
This is the longest two seconds of my life.
I found another car.
It's fine.
I'm with you.
Oh, it's the final countdown, guys.
Two.
Guys, it's still at two, guys.
This is the longest two seconds of my life.
Honey, I'm coming home.
Honey.
That's the longest two seconds.
It's still at two.
Where am I?
I'm not controlling the cat.
One.
Oh, no.
We got that.
We're here.
We're at least...
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
Come on.
Get away, bro.
At least we're here.
Okay.
I'm learning.
It's not fair.
These guys know how they play the game.
You guys know how...
It's so unfair though.
First game, you're fine.
Guys, they know how to play the game, guys.
I...
This is my first game.
This is...
We didn't even use the...
We didn't even use the tank.
We didn't use the tank.
Guys, we didn't use the tank, okay?
That's why we lost.
We didn't get to use the tank.
Don't miss out for future.
Alright, we figured it out, guys.
Now it's so open.
The sniper fucking sucks.
That's what I figured out.
The sniper is... It's all about close range, I feel like.
Turn that down a little?
I feel like it should be the sound effects, right?
Maybe I just need to turn it down a little more.
Play sound in the background?
What the fuck does that mean?
I'll just play this.
Put that lower.
Okay, let's test the gun out.
Yeah, let me know if it fixes it.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, it's a Demoman!
It's Demoman!
Okay.
Let me know.
Let me know, sound guy.
Is it better?
Yeah!
Try another gun?
Okay, I'll try the battle rifle.
Oh, this one you have to click.
You can't hold this.
There's so many different guns.
That was a match of chaos.
Indeed, indeed.
Okay.
Yo, froggy, man.
This is so slow.
It's a very slow gun.
Oh, this is the heal gun!
And then there's the shotgun.
Shotgun sounds like a gun.
You may have to talk to Kimmy again.
Yeah.
There's so many different guns.
I feel like the sniper fucking sucks.
That's not... That's my opinion.
Out of all the guns...
The sniper... What is this supposed to... The sniper damage is not that great.
Or like the projectile is so slow.
There were moments where I was like, that had to be a hit.
You know?
I was like, that should be a hit, but it didn't hit.
I don't know if it's like the projectile... It's not like full hit scan or something.
Yeah, the damage is pretty meh.
That's what I didn't like about the sniper.
I feel like the damage was better on the other guns.
Nah, this one's cooler.
This is the best sniper apparently.
Is this the best sniper?
Yeah, it is.
Or this one.
It's purple.
Oh!
That's a good damage.
Yeah.
Tire... Tire hard or whatever?
That's good damage.
That's a really good damage.
Yeah, that's... That's Kraber right there.
I want a 1v1.
Oh wait, is this a shop?
He's still in the lobby.
He's still in his lobby.
Froggy.
He's still... He's still down below.
I got to talk to Gibby.
He's bouncing around.
Well done.
Okay.
This is so... Okay.
The whole theme is 80s, guys.
I'm tired of losing these gunfights to him.
There's more to them.
You might realize...
Froggy is a nuisance.
To get some insights into the more advanced functions.
Turn over to Chip.
How do I swap my loadout?
Shop.
Okay.
I completed it.
I want to swap my loadout.
Oh wait.
He's got this... Yeah, it's basically 80s.
I'm surprised they got the music rights for the final countdown.
Tell me about the shops.
There are two things you can do.
Banking.
And your team to spend later.
Using any held or banked prize.
Something nice for yourself.
Yeah.
Wait.
So...
I do.
That's... Okay.
That's pretty crazy.
So it's very, very highly incentivized for everyone on the team to come and deposit their bank.
Because it gives everyone on the team money.
But if I'm spending cash, it doesn't affect the cash that you guys have.
Yeah, exactly.
Wow.
Cool concept.
Very.
I'm doing a tutorial.
Because I didn't want to buy stuff.
That first match, I have only bought literally two things.
I don't want to take from other people.
But yeah, that's actually really freaking dope.
Yeah, it's kind of hard to explain that concept without the guide you get given.
You have to actually work together.
Okay.
Yeah, I already... No, please don't show me again.
I thought this was over.
I thought the tutorial was over.
It's like, let me show that again.
How did they...
Oh, is this part of the Power Glove?
My homeboy said, y'all hiring.
Oh.
I see.
So I'm healing.
I heal.
I'm healing.
Oh, that's a heal.
I thought that was a fucking Gibraltar shield.
That's why I didn't shoot the fucking yellow aura.
I was like, that's a barrier right there.
Oh!
That was a fucking...
Okay.
I was like, oh, I'm going to stop shooting that.
That's a heal.
That was a fucking barrier.
I'm this purple because it's based off my girlfriend.
She has purple hair.
It's her favorite color too.
I see.
You watch exactly what you're trying to shoot.
I'm warded.
I'm figuring it out.
Okay, guys.
So.
How do people have names?
Before we get started in the game two here, you might have... you might have... you will have another objective from Gibi.
Ico, did you run them through this yet by chance?
I have an objective from Gibi?
Yeah.
I talked to a few of them here at the time.
All right.
Cool.
Do I?
If you haven't talked to Gibi, go talk to Gibi.
Complete the rest of the objectives after you're done talking to Gibi.
He showed me the shop four times.
You can go talk to the chip.
He's going to yap like I do.
And then once you're done talking to the chip, you're going to do one action here.
Why do I still need to talk to him?
He's just saying the same thing.
Yeah, we're going to stick with the same team.
Unfortunately, we can't bring Grim in.
It looks like our game is just not working with him at all.
We're going to put him out of his misery today and not waste his time.
That couldn't be me.
I did my homework and I showed up.
Oh, I have to talk to him after he shows me stuff?
Now let's pretend you're carrying another 100 pounds.
Go ahead and pop it in.
So...
Oh, that's why I kept repeating it.
I just had a question and it just left me.
What's the target price for this?
Good question.
I know, but I can't share it.
But I can say...
This is not going to be Call of Duty levels of expensive.
Guys, I get to play this for free.
We know it's not $70 for the base.
$195 for the next edition.
Well, I mean, you don't actually know that.
He simply said it's not going to be Call of Duty levels of expensive.
That doesn't tell us if it's going to be higher than Call of Duty.
Or lower than Call of Duty.
I'll tell you right now.
It's not going to be $70.
And it ain't going to be...
Honestly, I thought it was going to be free to play.
Talk to Gibby.
It's not going to be $65.
I can say that.
Don't worry.
I think they learned from Concord.
Don't worry, I did.
I guess the real objective is to get those...
Oh my god, can I finally get a purse?
Once he got in the trailer, he put his head back to another frame.
Oh my god, he got a purse!
He put his head back to the lobby in general.
Unlocks additional things and gives you progress.
It's generalizing progress, right?
You get cores in matches and then it progresses you outside of matches.
That way you can go back into matches stronger.
What the fuck?
Why?
It's not fair.
All the other people I played against had all of this.
When it comes to a victor in the match, right?
Is there an ideal victor?
Or if each team...
There's only three cores, right?
Yes, there's only three cores.
Custom weapons?
And then there's currently, we're playing with four teams of three.
Yes.
So if three of those teams all get one core...
We're carrying keycard, it'll be used to be later.
Okay.
I wanna be fast.
And then I wanna increase my melee damage.
What's my utility?
The way that the victory process works in here is two ways.
Oh, I have so many perks.
One, your objective is just so linear.
You get a biocore.
Even if you die and you still manage to extract a biocore at your home base.
And you die, like lose life completely.
I'll never die.
That is the overall premise of the game.
So I won't get the power insurance.
When it comes to the actual MVP...
When you have reached to swap it out or to add a custom weapon.
That's not fair.
Right.
The more kills you get, the more support you offer.
Okay, we're not gonna do sniper anymore.
Sniper fucking sucks.
I found out.
Okay, what's the...
So, it's not exactly...
There is benefit out of getting...
I'll get the shotgun first.
I feel like shotgun is like the best.
Which is getting all three biocores.
But if you get all three biocores, like that's just better for you.
All three of you now have...
All four...
All three of you now have three biocores.
Wait, what the fuck?
In this case, don't look at it...
Oh, this is when you get the biocore.
At like the same type of objective style based arena style shooter.
Everybody can...
Only one team can come out not successful.
And that's it.
Right.
Okay.
Because pretty much I was trying to differentiate...
What are we waiting for?
In the sense of...
Yeah, it feels like there is...
What is the...
There's so many times where I have to shotgun people.
Because we got a biocore.
And I think like two other teams had gotten like the other two.
Demoman.
But I was like, if we got a biocore, then like...
Or is it like...
Oh, I can't shoot this in public.
But essentially, overall...
I have to shoot it in the fire range.
Casual.
You know, people who are more casual, right?
Came into play.
Is that they don't have to...
Oh, I can't shoot this in public.
We can have a biocore and have some stress about winning or loosing.
Because the only personal goal is to extract those biocores.
They can be completely passive...
And get biocores and then get completely dumped on, right?
They lose all of their lives.
This is crazy the amount of damage...
But as long as they got at least 1 biocore, then they can vibe out, play this game...
I can't tear that people in public.
Booo...
I want to play...
When it comes to the general battle for the biocore...
What if I just que up right now?
That's really cool.
We got two players...
There's gonna be a very simple matchmaking process for this, so whenever the game launches, you press Q of A13 through SQM, and you'll have it in there as well.
But also, as far as the casualty...
Is there a left?
No.
Oh, there is, but I don't think it matters.
I don't think ADSing on the shotgun really matters.
The experience there is gonna be very similar, but in this case, it's still going to be...
Like, there's no power-up for ADSing.
Who's yapping?
A dev and a player.
You're learning about the game.
Mid-range?
Um, look at how far they are.
How do I get this?
Oh, there it is!
Toggle target?
Oh, how do I get them closer?
How do I get them closer?
Oh, there it is.
Right now, I'm just rambling, just as you do.
So now we're rambling each other.
Then I was thinking about how...
Wait, there's no power-up!
If we have time to talk afterwards then yeah.
Okay.
There it is.
Wait, what the fuck?
That's crazy!
Wait, what?
Oh, there's the end.
Oh, there it is.
Perfect.
There you go.
Guys, it wasn't me.
Me?
I can't promise.
I did get out of one.
How big are the aerial leaves for these?
I just...
I don't know.
She knew we do not have the end.
That's a clue.
I don't want to hear that question ever again in my life.
Guys, I didn't know!
I realized we were waiting for me in the end!
You said you got it twice.
I got it twice.
It's a horrible day to have yours.
It didn't show up in the corner!
It didn't!
Is everyone in the team searching for Matthew?
I was looking for him in the corner.
I know!
Everyone is searching for Matthew at the top of the screen.
Matthew...
Oh, okay.
Perfect.
Yeah!
Let's go.
Guys, look how he's dying!
It was me!
Yeah, it will be a different team number, so just keep an eye on that bottom left and you'll know what team you need to be in.
Guys, I'm the little sister they brought along to the group hangout.
You can't blame me.
I don't know what's going on.
It was you all along.
Yeah, we filmed the hangout.
Okay, I figured it out now.
I know what to do this time.
Look at my loadout!
Look at all that shit!
Look at that!
I know what I'm doing this time.
If you look at my loadout, you can tell I know what I'm doing.
Look at my crop top.
Thanks, I worked really hard for that.
Nice.
Ooh, I forgot.
I made a new weapon and I named it P. Diddy.
Oh gosh.
Is that just for me?
I hope not.
We should win now.
I have every perk of it.
I don't know.
We can't lose this time.
They're with Winton.
Team 2.
Perfect.
Guys, we can do this.
I know how to play the game now.
Okay.
Harmony, huh?
Sounds like my time.
Are you ready to win this time?
Yeah, I know how to play this time.
It's over.
Where are the snails?
There's the snails hiding.
Oh, they're hiding?
Okay, I'm gonna go right side.
Okay, guys, I'm gonna find the snails, guys.
How's chat feeling about it?
Oh, see?
Look, I did it!
I found...
Are they, like, bullying you to win?
They love the game.
Right, guys?
You guys love the game, right?
Guys, even if you don't like it, please lie.
I need this spot.
No, I'm joking.
Where are these snails from?
I found one.
Froggy and I were talking about it.
We noticed that, like, if you kind of just circle around, the snail will spawn back where you are.
Whoa, what the fuck is that?
Oh my god, you can...
Walk up and press E, you can ride them.
Wait, we can ride them by shot?
Yeah, no, no, just walk up.
Just walk up and press E.
But I shot him.
I pressed E.
I don't think he likes me.
Trust me, I'd never lead you astray.
Okay, but he hit me and now I lost HP.
So, I'm leaving.
Wait, do I kill him?
Yeah, you kill him.
I killed you?
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, alright, alright.
You just shit?
Nice.
Wait, I need tears.
Wait, I have, like, this F key, what is that?
What am I holding?
That's gonna be your utility key.
So you'll be able to use things like traps.
Oh, I have a tracker, Glen!
Yeah, so, like, you throw it, and it's remote.
It's not remote detonation, it's movement detonation.
So, like, you throw it, and if somebody walks past it, they're going to be highlighted for you.
Oh, I see.
Get out of here, snail.
That's fucking right.
Alright, cool.
We have a lot of power, so I think we're good to go to A and scan for the next biocore here.
Guys, type in my...
Guys, after the stream, type in my comment section and be like, game of the year.
And then be like, Jedi is my favorite dev.
In the comments.
And be like, Jedi is my favorite developer.
Alright, I actually think it would be better if we put our power here.
Shields.
There we go.
We can go take a peek at the shop.
What is this?
Take item?
Yeah, yeah.
So you know how the first game we walked up to that shop Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can actually buy shields from your respawn base.
Oh, I see.
It costs just a little bit more.
It costs 100 more power.
Oh, I see.
I'm going to put my shotgun out just in case, guys.
I have no more power, but we do have 200.
Wait, I didn't deposit my power.
I've added power to the team bank.
I put some.
There's a score creeper.
Try to buy this score creeper.
Score creeper.
I'm buying it.
Got me a sweet battle rifle.
Totally rad.
Beam glove secured.
I just want to poke around a little bit.
There's usually some pretty...
Oh my god, look at this.
You can have this.
Get over here.
Pick one up.
Pick up the shiny.
There's a shiny?
There's a shiny.
Oh, it's tier 4!
I'll never die.
Guys, I'm being fed so much.
What the hell is that?
These are shield repairs.
Wait, what?
Here, here, here.
This right here on the ground is a shield repair.
Use your...
Apex brain it.
Use 4k to heal.
Oh, I see, I see.
Wait, I hear gunshots outside.
Yeah, I do too.
I don't want to look at it yet.
I want to do just a little bit more...
Looting.
On me, on me!
Okay.
Oh, I passed.
Oh no, I'm getting healed.
By the aura.
I'm grabbing the shotgun.
I feel like the shotgun is better, chat.
I don't know, the rifle feels so...
Not rifle, but like...
Broke.
It's like 33...
I hit 33.
On me, on me!
On me!
Oh, I got it down?
What the fuck happened there?
Oh, no.
Alright, I'm gonna push here.
They have one down.
There's only two of them.
Oh, okay.
Oh, dude, he's dead.
Dude, I killed Iceman.
That was sick.
28 flesh.
Here's one!
I'm gonna chop him behind.
Oh, he's right here, right here.
Yeah.
Wait, is there friendly fire?
Nice.
Oh, yoink.
That's the mob.
Is this a better shotgun?
Oh, it is!
Okay.
Oh, there's people coming into the shop.
Oh, okay.
I'm like, I need some shields.
Have you got any energy ammo?
Yeah, yeah, I got some here.
Here, Doki, I'm gonna drop some shields for you.
Uh, I have...
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I have some energy.
You said you need ammo here.
Sure thing.
Let's do it.
Alright, now with these beam gloves, you can also do this little AOE right here, so you can get in the bubble.
And also, she can heal you.
Oh, okay.
It doesn't heal as good as, like, a lock-on heal, but, you know, it's...
But it's just AOE.
Yeah, it's just AOE.
Oh, above me, above me.
Oh, there's so many people!
I don't see shit!
They're all up up there.
What do you mean they're there?
Oh, frag grenade.
That's my nade.
Okay, I'm backing out a little bit.
Oh my god, I'm so fucked.
I'm so fucked.
Ah!
Right here in front of me!
Down.
I'm backing out a little.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
Oh, got it.
Me too.
Ah, no!
He headshot me!
No!
I was trying to shoot you, Ico.
Oh my god.
Is it friendly fire?
I thought no.
I just thought she was a bad person.
It's okay.
I'm alive.
But, like, at what cost?
Help.
They had gold shields too, bro.
They had gold shields.
Okay, that's not fair.
I'm just gonna die here.
Get that shotgun.
Come on.
It takes so long to reload the shotgun.
I noticed.
Yeah, chat.
It takes so long.
I'm not ready.
Like, I shot one bullet, and I was like, reload.
I was like, why did I do that?
And this whip?
Yeah, teammates can block shots.
The Mustang that I'm driving, it's fully customizable too.
You can, like, make it look cool as shit.
So when you pull up the Shorty's house, you can be like, Hey, what's up, baby mama?
What the fuck?
He's stuck in the 80s right now.
I don't think he knows it's 2024.
By the way, this dev's awesome.
I'm really gonna comment that on the VOD.
Are we gonna make it?
I don't keep up for a big fight.
Oh, shit.
He's down.
I need heals, though.
I'm fucking low.
Oh, next one.
Yeah.
I got you.
Give me my shield.
Dude, no way they actually got that off.
Unlucky.
We were right down.
One's super weak right now.
He is?
Oh, he's dead.
Okay.
There's another squad right here.
Killed by a girl.
So embarrassing.
I'm behind you, Jay.
No, I don't want that.
Give me my gun.
Gotta reload.
Cover me, dudes.
Wait, what?
What happened?
Oh, it's an airstrike.
What the fuck?
There's airstrikes?
Okay, I'm okay.
Where are you?
He's dead.
I got literally deleted by Thanos.
Wait, how is there an airstrike?
So, uh, you remember that EMP I was talking about last game?
Yeah.
The airstrike is also like a manually triggered event.
Oh!
Okay.
Whenever you start the match, you'll be able to see where it's at on the map.
And you just go straight.
You can go straight towards it, just fire it right off.
Oh, I see.
That's fun.
And we have a lot more.
So we've got stuff like lightning strikes.
We've also got toxic chambers.
Right now, we're on the top ground.
We haven't gone underground yet.
We have a full underground area of the map as well.
And it's huge.
Okay.
You can flood it with toxic gas to force people out.
Also, we have this one thing.
You can see everybody on the map.
It's kind of cool.
Give me my shield.
That's one last catamon in the forest.
Some of them require a little bit of work.
Some of them are pretty easy to just activate.
Oh, I see.
So they just activate it.
But why would they activate it on us?
It depends on what it is.
So like, for example, the airstrike tower, right?
It's obvious.
You want to drop an airstrike on where there's a lot of people so that way you can get as many kills as possible and deal as much damage.
Oh, I see.
So they just wanted the kills.
Yeah, yeah.
And it really depends.
It's situational, right?
How do you use the event to your tactical advantage to secure a biocore or just create friction in any kind of firefight?
If you want to be a troll, you can.
But everybody knows where you're at.
Everybody knows where you're at when you're doing it.
It's okay, I don't because I wasn't paying attention.
I'm not gonna lie, I wasn't paying attention either.
Oh, we need fire.
What the fuck is this gun recoil?
There's people in front of me?
Sniper on the prowl.
Trying to ruin my totally bitchin' day.
Oh, there's a sniper somewhere.
Bro, the hipfire for this gun is like weird too, guys.
I would admit.
We can rush him, we can rush him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's two teams though.
What was that, two?
Yeah, yeah, there's two teams fighting.
You know what we can do?
We can try and do the airstrike.
The airstrike's reloaded.
Yeah, yeah, let's go to the airstrike.
Let's go light people on fire.
I got two knocks though on me.
He's shredding.
Biocore B is 50% complete.
Melee them so you can get your shield back too.
Melee them.
Yeah.
Okay, nice.
I can hit people on me.
Okay.
Oh, there's one right here.
Right below you right now.
What gun do I have?
No visuals.
I hear people behind me.
There's one behind you.
I'm over here.
Okay, we can't shoot through that.
Should we get the biocore?
We can.
Let's go through this window up here.
Ooh.
Sniper douchebag on you, my dudes.
There's a sniper somewhere.
Damn chump trying to pin me down.
I broke somebody in here.
Oh, on you?
Oh my god.
This is like a full... what?
Whoa.
Yeah.
Insta headshot.
Bitch.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, I got insta headshot.
What's that?
Why can't I do that damage?
I want that guy's gun.
I want that guy's fucking gun.
What gun is that?
What the fuck?
Why can't I see what gun killed me?
I just see killed by Iceman.
What kind of gun was that?
Okay.
Well, we can't play for C since we know B is a little bit of a pain in the ass to go grab.
Biocore rescue underway.
I have some power too.
This is more kind of adventure.
What's the point?
You know what?
Maybe sniper is good.
Whatever sniper that guy has, bro, fuck that guy.
I want that guy's gun.
I've added some juice to the team bank.
Oh, I don't have any.
Alright, here.
I'm gonna give you something cool.
Okay.
What is it?
I'm gonna give you P Diddy.
What is that?
A custom weapon.
This is my cheat code to you.
Is this a sniper?
This is a sniper.
It's a very special sniper.
It should have a faster ADS and it should also heal you whenever you hit them.
Oh, if I hit the shot?
Okay, let's go to C.
It should do like 5% shield repair.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm heading up.
Okay, you guys go.
I'm just gonna snipe.
Wait.
Should we go to B?
I would say go to C.
C is really close.
We're literally right next to it.
I see people next to me.
There's a heart in here.
Oh!
Okay.
Bro, stop ADSing.
Yes, okay.
They're over here fighting right now and I'm...
I knocked somebody.
Yeah, dude.
They're still over there.
We wanna do anything about it.
Oh, there's a purple shield down here.
Do you wanna...
Bring it up.
Taxi it.
Taxi it?
Yeah, taxi it.
He's dead.
Alright, where are you?
I'm up top.
I actually like...
I think I'm gonna ban everybody who uses the Spore Creeper, dude.
I cracked him several times.
Stop it.
The bio-gat thing is right over here next to us.
Let's go grab it.
I cover.
I can cover.
Oh, there's a team in here.
Oh, he's one!
He's one!
Behind you!
Oh, dude!
I got fucking deleted.
Wait, can you rez him?
I can cover.
Yeah, I should be relatively safe.
You're rez-able.
Yeah, they're not looking at you.
The EMP'd.
They're looking at me, so...
Okay.
I downed him.
Nice!
Hey, I think I like this gun, guys.
I think...
Boom, baby!
Oh, nice!
I got a kill!
Oh, there's people in this room on me.
He is right next to us right now.
Right here.
He's coming up.
Wait, where are you guys?
Broke.
I don't even know how to get to you guys.
Should we go to...
Oh, above me.
Above me.
On the roof.
Coming.
I don't know where he went.
He's literally there with me.
Because I don't want to lose my sniper, guys.
So, if you die, I can get it back.
Oh, okay.
Can we go to B?
They're literally chilling.
No, no, no.
We're good.
We are chilling even more.
Like, right now, we have access to B very easily.
If you want to take potshots, I'm not going to tell you no.
If you want to take potshots, and then you buy me back the sniper.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
What is this thing?
Alright, I'll grab my club.
I'm going to head over.
Holy shit, it's so far!
Guys, I won't lose the...
Guys, it's going to be okay, guys.
If I die, the devs are going to give me their legendary armor.
And then they're going to give me another sniper, guys.
Guys, I won't die.
There's no way.
Guys, trust me.
He's going to...
Okay.
He's going to give me his...
He's going to give me his armor.
He has an orange armor.
And then he's going to...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm getting that B.
I'm getting those kills.
You're not going to expect it.
I believe, I believe.
They don't know.
They're like, where is she?
I really don't know.
They know where I am.
Wait, dowsing effect?
Oh, is that the gun poison?
Yeah.
So, there are status effects that you can...
That you can deal.
Oh.
I see.
So, like, there's fire, there's poison.
Uh...
I think that's their ammo.
Guys, I'm coming back.
I'm scared.
Guys, I'm walking in a straight line.
There might be a life.
I'm so scared.
Oh, fuck!
Guys, I'm so scared.
I'm getting shot at.
You win these.
You're fine.
There's an airstrike for sure.
Oh!
They'll never expect me in the fucking water.
I swear to god.
If I die in the water, I swear to fucking god.
Yo, get in here!
Get in here, snail!
No!
You're gonna be coming behind some people they'll see.
Oh, shit!
Come on, get over here.
There's snails that you can kill.
I'm coming.
We're both behind you.
He's so low!
That's fucking where you're scared now, you bitch!
Guys, guys.
Please.
She's so low.
Give me my shield back.
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
Okay.
Yay!
Did we win?
We won!
We did it!
Yay!
We did it.
We just needed a warm up match.
We just needed to understand the game.
She needed a warm up match and P Diddy.
I just need that gun.
I need that gun.
And that gun right there is an example of how the game encourages you to try shit out.
You could literally build that game.
So, another cool thing.
Imagine I killed you with that gun, right?
Yeah.
And you picked it up and you tried it yourself.
Oh my god, guys!
I got six kills!
Look at these losers with zero!
On the top of your death screen, you can actually see what weapons you were dead by.
And you can copy people's guns and make it yourself.
Oh!
That's cool!
So, how do I copy again?
You won't be able to copy right now, but whenever you die, and you look at the top left of your respawn screen, it's gonna show you how you died, who killed you.
Click on where it says how you died.
It'll show the gun that killed you.
That's the most damage!
And it saves it to your profile.
And then you just go straight over to a weapons terminal.
Oh!
And it'll be like, hey, here's a gun that you copied.
This is how you build it.
Wait, since you're a dev, can you just put the gun in my account?
Uh, not with this build, no.
Oh, okay.
I'm trying to get those cheats already.
It's just easier, Chad!
There is actually a streamer mode.
If you go to the audio, tap on the settings.
No, it's okay.
She's like, it stays.
It's okay.
I want to listen to the copyright music.
I'm still...
I'm still to this day...
Because I have the most damage.
I'm gaming.
This is my second game.
And I'm the most damaged, Chad.
I'm out of time.
I'm fucking gaming.
I have more damage than the fucking developer.
Let's see what happens with everybody when they come back in.
Toki supports small, multi-million dollar brands.
You know who needs more money?
The guy who fucking made the final countdown.
Like, it's not like they play that song every fucking New Year's or anything.
As it gets closer to New Year's.
That guy definitely needs more money.
Alright, some battle rifle mods.
Oh!
Where's Jenny?
True, you know what?
True.
They just had a mega contest.
Guys, you don't understand.
They're wiping their tears with only $50 bills.
I want them to wipe their tears with $100 bills.
Like...
Oh, that's weird.
Because I have more damage than the developer.
And the amount of times he's played this fucking game.
Guys, I'm a gamer.
How kind.
Oh, we're all talking to her.
Yes!
Let's start something just by hooking up.
Okay.
A medium barrel fitter that reduces recoil.
Bro, everybody has such fucking insane guns!
All these people.
Now I got the recoil thingy.
Wait, equip the medium dampener to a battle rifle and save it.
Okay.
That's a weapon.
I'm not created anything yet.
Oh, you can move people?
How dare you move me?
Oh, I have a key card.
That wasn't me.
I don't have that at all.
Wait, I can buy a key card!
I can shift it to another room.
Alrighty, guys.
How are we feeling right now?
Game three right now.
We could do one more if everyone's got time.
If everyone's got interest.
I won't be hurt if you don't.
Wait, where's the vault?
I'm down.
Alright, have fun.
Alright, cool.
So, before we get into game three, we're gonna play hide and seek here in the lobby.
It's built into the game.
So, go to the disco room.
Follow everybody into the disco room.
I said I was sliding around.
There we go.
Doki got a taste of the custom weapons.
Wait, can you like unlock all the stuff for me?
I cannot.
Give me an unlocker.
So, Jay, is game three gonna be give custom weapons?
Hey, it doesn't hurt to ask, guys.
It doesn't hurt to ask.
I know both of y'all are also so feel free to have fun.
I want Glossy!
We'll make my guns sparkle!
So, right down over here, it's a hide and seek.
It's gonna count down and allow you to sign up.
And once you register, you're gonna see names, your name as well, on the top right screen.
Once you see your name up there, that means you are registered for hide and seek.
As soon as you see it, go hide.
Go find somewhere to hide.
Okay.
Yo.
Be that person I have right in the front room.
Wait, are we going up first?
No.
Do we go up first?
He didn't sign up.
Wait, I didn't sign up?
I thought I did.
No.
Oh, okay.
I'm in a different place, anyway, so.
Okay.
This game, this is basically infection in any video game you've ever played.
One person's gonna be the infector, and they have to find everybody.
And once they infect that person, that person is now infecting the other person.
So it's hide and seek, but infection.
Guys, do you think I can pull off the Gibby stance?
Maybe.
Okay, but like...
Wait.
What if I'm on...
Oh no, where do I hide?
What do you mean there's never been two NPCs?
Where do I hide?
There's 10 sec...
Why is there so many people here?
They'll never find me here, bro.
Oh my god, they'll never find me here because I'm going so far away from the fucking map.
There's no way.
I hate it here.
I had a feeling that was gonna happen.
There's no way they're gonna...
That's why I didn't hide.
It's so far away from everybody, guys.
Nobody's gonna walk all the way here.
I saw you go hide.
My favorite thing about hide and seek is that you'll see people hide with you and you'll know exactly where to go.
Exactly.
Ah, shit.
There's no way.
It's so deep in the map there's no way they'd know the map well enough, chat.
Alright, so I'm gonna take five minutes just to go on Twitch and see who else is streaming that way I can...
Lil doesn't know I'm not on Twitch, guys.
He's stream sniping.
Doesn't know I'm not on Twitch.
It's not stream sniping.
I don't have a sniper.
It's not that.
I'm not on Twitch.
He's never gonna know.
Nobody got caught yet.
There's more to this map?
Yep.
How fucking far is this?
Does it turn off the name tag over your head?
Yes, it does.
Nobody can see you when they're in the Infector.
No one expects a YouTube stream, right?
Which means what you could do is just stand around like an NPC.
Sorry, I have a person here.
What every NPC looks like.
I was like, who the fuck is this guy?
That's why there was a dead end right over here.
We've just spent too much time in the lobby, Wynton.
Oh shit, you're right.
I'm hiding with a Twitch streamer.
Oh no.
Uh oh.
Saw a naked man in the corner, bro.
That's not no damn NPC.
It's okay.
This map is so deep, they won't know.
Damn it.
How?
We didn't get caught last first, so it's fine.
Bro, right when you say, is that oiled up cheeks, I turn a corner and I see cheeks.
You're right, maybe I should keep it.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe I'll be in the middle.
This should've been a better spot here.
It should've gave me a little bit more time.
Every time you gate somebody.
It's not fair!
If the dev gets caught, they'll know every fucking area in the map.
We had a completely different lobby before this one.
And it had a lot of cheeky hiding spots.
It was fun.
So we're adding more.
There's more?
You could be anywhere.
No!
The thing!
Oh shit, wait, there's more than one person.
Wait, I just remembered, there's more than one person trying to kill me.
You should've been behind you.
That's crazy.
You literally could be behind somebody and they wouldn't hear you.
No.
That's crazy.
I was trying to bait him.
I wanted to bait him.
I was trying to get a full 360.
Kick again.
Maybe look up.
Oh, you beat it!
He's so locked in!
You can't find him.
You're trying your best.
He's so locked in right now.
Is that you, Nico?
You did the same thing as you did yesterday.
Wait a minute.
Ignore me.
I'm not here.
Don't worry about it.
Ignore me.
I think that is you.
He's a little guy.
They don't know.
They don't know this area.
JJ!
Wait, there's two, four, six, seven.
Got him.
Guys, I'm already halfway through.
I need everyone to panic right now.
Not my favorite.
I think they found Froggy, no?
Yeah, we found Froggy.
Oh, he's not dead.
No!
Wow!
I found out.
I saw him hide.
Oh, on top of that machine.
Yo, what's up, bro?
Oh my gosh.
Y'all are fighting everybody, bro.
What's up?
Wait.
Please don't.
Please.
I don't know where to go!
They did it!
Who's not talking?
I'm just like, where the fuck do I go?
You're just standing there.
Let me look behind you.
No, try.
No way.
This is not fair!
Why would you take a shower?
Why?
Why the fuck did you do this?
Somebody gotta find us and make this movie.
No escape.
We got 29 seconds.
This is bullshit.
This is so bullshit.
I can't believe it.
So fucked.
Who's that?
Who's that I'm looking at?
Oh, it's two of you.
Three of you.
I'm actually so fucked.
Oh, no way.
Oh, wow.
It almost worked.
I'm so fucked, man.
Damn it.
I'm so sad.
Hold on.
No way.
Look.
No.
Wow.
That's cheating.
I'm just standing in the rock.
What the fuck?
The moment I go down there.
You were in that spot.
What the fuck?
How the fuck did you get there?
I just died.
This is wild.
There's two rocks I found.
You can stand inside.
Oh, yeah.
Wow.
This one you can get even crazier with it.
Nah, that's OD.
These people are OD.
This is not how you see me.
Where am I?
I know where I am.
Nah.
This is not okay.
Bro, all of you could have been right here.
These guys have played so long.
Guys, I won.
And they fucking played for so long.
Guys, most damage?
And they played for how long?
You know what?
Guys, I'm happy with how well I'm doing.
They played for how long?
And I got most damage in this fucking lobby?
I just died.
I was crazy.
Nobody was looking for me.
Maybe it wasn't looking for you.
They should have had the same weapon.
If they played for so long.
They should be able to custom make the same weapon.
You said you were gonna sit over.
I'm so humble.
Guys, they tried to give me a controller that wasn't pregnant.
I deserve this.
If there's no one on the screen, press P and there should be one next to my name.
Guys.
Please complete my mission.
I can't even.
Okay, where is my mission?
Guys, please.
I can't be the last one.
Okay, there we go.
Here we go.
Yeah, go talk to Chip.
There we go.
I complete my mission.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Do I need a vial core to Jenny?
Who's Jenny?
Oh, that's her.
Don't.
It's not me.
That's for sure.
I'm not that guy.
I have a vial core for you.
Oh, yeah.
Most of the character's items will be locked behind a reputation requirement.
This character belongs.
Donating vial cores to a character.
Okay.
Where do you think you're going to go?
Well done.
I did it.
To the left of the firing range you can interact with.
Iko, the only thing I'm not saying is that you're not readied up.
No, he's just doing the Jenny mission.
Oh, okay.
What?
You don't need to wait for me.
It's not me.
You don't have to wait for me.
I keep donating?
Yes, I do.
Yeah, go talk to that guy.
Why did I get called out?
I have to customize the weapon.
Take your time with it.
We can just do it.
So, when the weapon stats, when the power increases, why are the numbers red?
Why is it doing the missions because it was there?
Can you build a weapon?
Yeah, so like, traditionally, green is better, red is worse.
But when you have the standard barrel, right?
Your power is at 125.
When you equip the medium barrel, the damper, the red numbers go up by 110.
Like, insane gun customization.
Yeah, I'm readied up, guys!
I'm readied up.
Is this my stream?
Nerd.
Oh, so that's why it's red.
Okay.
Alright, and power being the currency in-game.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Sorry, I had to step away quickly.
But I did get the question.
Eiko, were you answering it?
No.
I got it.
Sorry about that.
No.
I didn't mean to step away like that.
I see how you are.
Because I was calling you.
The custom thing might be, like, hard for you to get used to.
I'm gonna be honest, man.
You're being out-rizzed.
Oh, wait.
We?
Wait, let's see what you're selling.
Oh, this is the EMP.
She has home advantage, quite literally.
If anyone's interested to know what I got called to, she was like, come here, come here.
I was like, what the f- Oh my god, I thought it was like an emergency.
She's making dinner right now.
She found an egg with two yolks in it.
Oh, I could get a hacker.
I wouldn't use it.
Wait, they have they have reputation 3?
That just means double- How fucking much did they play?
Let me know how it turned out.
Alright.
My man.
Bro.
He has reputation 3.
God, I wish that were me.
That's crazy.
You know what this guy, the developer's voice sounds like?
She goes, come here, come here.
I look at her, she's like, it's twins.
I can't help but think, because I used to watch Overwatch streamers and also play a lot of Overwatch, he literally sounds like Emon.
He's an Overwatch streamer.
I couldn't get it out of my head when I was like, that's Emon.
He's an Overwatch OG.
I just see him as Emon, but what if instead of maxing out on Overwatch, he maxes out on game devs in the 80s?
What if it is Emon?
Am I Insider?
What am I?
80s Emon.
Wait, get more pricks?
I don't have a lot.
What other pricks do I have?
Yeah, I don't have anymore.
Guys, I'm broke.
I'm new here.
Emon is so good.
They made the two.
And Emon in each game.
He literally sounds like Emon.
Most wins?
Boom.
54?
Boom, that's good.
Here we go.
So this is the last one of the night?
Yep, this is the last one.
Bro, he only played two games.
How did he fucking have 54?
We got our feedback.
Just go ahead and make them quit.
Yeah, go ahead and get your custom weapons.
Do your work.
Now I can brag.
He just really likes the 80s.
That would be a truly epic gamer moment.
Oh, where's me?
Shotgun.
Okay.
I'm gonna still keep the shotgun.
I think the shotgun is the best in terms of what I have.
In terms of default-wise, this is like all I can have.
That means he has enough time to do at least enough games to get 54 wins while waiting for the matches to start, guys.
That doesn't make it better.
He was in the lobby long enough during playtest.
Are you talking about that Oreo Coca-Cola again?
Alright, let's go.
He spat around them.
Guys, I told you I didn't need a ping.
I never pinged once.
Did I ping?
No, I didn't.
I didn't ping at all.
Where the fuck are the snails?
Snails?
Where are the snails?
It's time to...
It's time to kill all snails.
Frog.
Hello, frog.
Hello.
Where is it?
Yeah, never ping.
Keep your team guessing exactly.
I'm just parkouring until I find a snail.
But where is the fucking snail?
I've seen one.
Why did we...
Can you, like, in developer chat, just add snails in our area?
Like...
If I actually had the tools for this version, I would abuse the hell out of it.
But I genuinely...
Wait, why don't you have it?
This is a locked down version of the game to ensure...
They locked it?
Not everybody.
So make sure everybody can have access to it.
Wait, so who has the power?
Nobody.
There is no power.
There's no... Why are you playing this version instead of the other version?
Because other people can use it.
Yeah, but they won't.
You're convincing me.
They won't.
Oh, is this a... Oh, no, it's just a mega smoke.
Dude, where the fuck... How many... Okay, you know what?
We've got enough power.
Let's just get the hell out of here.
They'll only abuse it for me, child.
Like...
The developers, they wouldn't abuse it.
The developers wouldn't abuse it, guys.
Yeah, this is LG anyway.
I can't believe it.
They locked it down.
So I can't get...
Can't believe it.
I can't believe they would do such a thing.
I'm also trying to slam my dinner at the same time.
Guys, I just want one unfair advantage.
Like, just one.
I got half brown, eggs, and shortcut bacon.
I wouldn't, like, abuse it on purpose.
It's just gonna be an accident.
They'll be like, whoa.
What did I just accidentally picked up?
Just one, you know?
And if it turns into two, then it was a lovely coincidence.
Wait, where do we go?
We're gonna go to a shop, so that way we have all of our power.
There's a team here.
Wait, where?
Oh, on here.
Oh, there's another one in here.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm heading over.
Oh, dude.
I got shredded.
77?
Oh, there's two in there.
Yeah.
Oh, you...
That's unlucky.
Okay.
We got this.
Stokey carry.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go be up here for a sec.
Are they rezzing or no?
Can't tell.
We're both down.
Oh, someone behind me.
Oh, no.
Just play your life here, so that way you don't lose...
Fuck you.
I might be dead though.
Oh, wait.
He's...
He doesn't wanna...
Oh, that's why he doesn't wanna fight!
Okay.
Need some cover.
I now know why he didn't wanna fight.
Hold on.
Shields need a little tune-up.
Oh, shit.
He's looking at me.
Look at him back.
Stram down to death.
Calling in some fresh wheels.
Okay.
We're coming, Doki.
Oh, no.
No!
I have to reload!
I hate that!
Fuck you!
Dude, no way, bro.
Cause I just...
Okay, I'm fucking leaving.
I got one over here.
On me.
Why is Q's IJ?
Do you know?
I need a reload.
I'm gonna attempt this.
It's risky.
Okay.
Holy shit!
He has a red gun and he's still lost?
Shop shooter alert.
You're just better.
Dude.
Oh, my God.
Keep your sight.
Okay.
Wait.
Keep cover.
I'm gonna go scream in his fucking discord and tell him to fuck off.
Okay.
Now this...
I know this gun sucks.
Sorry.
You're out.
You're on your own.
This gun fucking sucks.
Well, Doki, if you run into the shop, actually, you have a lot of power.
I can get you a custom sniper.
Wait.
Sorry.
You might die here.
Honestly, I think I'm kinda cucked.
Okay.
I'm, like, inside.
Wait.
Can I rez you?
No.
You're dead.
Okay.
I'm gonna steal your stuff, though.
Oh!
Damn chump trying to pin me down.
That's why he lost.
Yeah!
The recoil is insane!
Holy shit!
All right.
I have my shotgun out.
That recoil was fucking crazy.
Do you have heals?
Yeah.
There's a health pack in here.
Come through this window.
Okay.
I'm genuinely afraid to leave right now.
This is so exciting.
I may have weed myself.
Oh, but I don't need...
I need shields.
That's a big one.
Watch your step.
Hmm.
If you go down to the shop down here, you can buy some shield repairs.
No.
I want a gun.
You want a gun?
Yeah.
I want a gun.
Do I deposit?
Yeah.
Go deposit.
Okay.
So, what have we got?
Gun tag.
Jay, how much is your sniper rifle?
I think it's like 600.
Shields up.
Got a tier 2 shield.
No.
It's 350.
Here.
I got it.
I'd say mine is like 800 or so.
Here you go.
P Diddy is all yours.
Oh!
I dropped this red gun.
It's garbage.
I'll take it.
Reclose.
Bad.
Oh, it's an SMG.
That's why.
Oh, Doki Doki.
Yeah?
You missed a sniper rifle as well.
Hey, what's this?
Wait.
Is that...
P Diddy.
Wait.
What gun did I get?
Yeah, that's a P Diddy sniper rifle I gave you last game.
Okay.
Can we go to A?
Yeah.
Let's go A.
Yeah, we go to A.
Where are people?
I'm scared.
Oh, I see him.
Don't worry.
I snipe.
Don't worry, guys.
Watch this.
I'm not going to lose my gun.
I swear.
Oh, yeah.
I hit 40.
Nice shot.
They're not peeking anymore.
On my left.
40.
I'm coming to you.
I pinged.
137.
Oh, damn.
Shredded him.
Oh, they got purple shields.
Wait.
I'm going to go thirst.
I'm thirsting.
Up here.
44.
He's broke up top.
Yeah.
I hit 44.
Eagle.
Staircase.
Beneath you.
Yep.
He went back up top.
He went down.
Wait.
They fell down?
There's two of them, man.
Some of them fell down.
I pinged.
Yeah.
They jumped off.
They're all inside right now.
It's just hard to like...
Oh.
Yeah.
I don't know what we could do there.
Be reliable.
I think we're dead, actually.
There's something going on down here, man.
There's somebody that went in on down there where I pinged.
They probably fell down.
Did that blow me?
Wait.
Am I hearing things?
I'm scared.
They might be inside.
I'm coming over to you.
I'm scared.
There's fights over here.
Did we get the A?
Did we get it?
Not yet.
It's got to reach 100%.
Oh.
Okay.
I'll just stay here then.
And die, I guess.
Somebody is shooting somebody down here.
I hear that.
Yeah.
Oh.
You can actually...
That might be...
Looks like they grabbed B.
I'm asking on.
Oh.
One right here.
48.
Broke.
Oh.
I shot his toesies.
Right here.
Three people.
I'm waiting for them to peek.
Down.
Nice.
Enemy down here.
What the fuck?
Oh.
You're scared.
You're fucking scared.
Oh.
What are you doing?
You take so much...
Why is A taking so long?
Compared to B.
Oh.
I think I have a hacking device, actually.
Yeah, they might have had a hacking device to meet here.
Oh...
I don't know...
Well, she did.
Those cheaters.
All right.
We're running this back to A.
If you want to camp, you can...
Yeah, yeah.
...ieni- Oh, where's C?
C hasn't been discovered yet.
So, you got to...
Oh, yeah.
You either gotta wait for it to unlock or you gotta scan for it.
Okay, I'll just wait here.
Or snipe.
Or die.
There's nobody here.
Everybody's quiet.
I think a lot of people lost a lot of lives in the very beginning.
Sniper douchebag on me, my dudes.
I'm better.
Anyone cheating, EJ?
That's fucking right, I'm still better.
I don't see no one.
That's fucking right, leave.
You know I'm better at sniping than you.
Oh, you're scared!
Yeah, that's right!
That's fucking right, run, bitch!
Okay, I need to find a snail.
Where the fuck are snails?
They don't deserve to live in the 80s.
Oh no.
I don't know where the snails are.
Don't keep toxic!
There's no more snails!
There is!
The fuck am I gonna survive?
I can only be alive when all the snails are dead in the 80s.
Guys, in the 80s.
Guys, have you guys seen any snails?
I fucking need some HP.
They're usually out in the forest.
Oh!
I see.
Oh, I found a shield repair.
Come drop me one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Only in the 80s, though, guys.
Only in the 80s when snail hate is relevant.
Here we go.
Nice.
Why didn't let me...
Oh, okay, I got it.
Let's get C.
Why snails?
Because you get your HP back from snails.
...
You're about to witness a heist so badass...
it'll be the stuff of legend.
Let's grab it before those other Tulses do.
Alright, where are you?
I really like... I really like this sniper.
All the other snipers were bad except for this one sniper.
I don't know how Oreo Coca Cola can taste like.
Ah, fuck!
Is this an American thing, chat?
Is it just vanilla?
I've never heard about Oreo.
Is that an American thing?
It just tastes like Oreo.
Yes?
Okay, no wonder.
Yeah, it seemed like an American thing.
I was like, I've never heard of Oreo Coca-Cola.
It's so good.
It sounds so American.
It does.
Oh!
Got me!
Chat, I am looking at you right now.
I stand my ground.
It's so good.
Stream sniper!
I can't believe it!
My dev stream snipes!
What about it?
You're lying.
The integrity!
Oh, I hit someone up in a door over here.
Yeah, there was like a guy next to me earlier, but he's gone.
You like how he got quiet the moment I yelled stream sniper?
Okay, he's right here.
People probably come here to fight him.
My favorite dev is a stream sniper.
Let's go!
Where is everybody?
How did they all die?
Frog, are you still in here?
What is that?
Oh, shit!
They're on me!
What, what, what?
They're on a car!
On me?
She's like a million miles above ground?
It's okay.
You guys are fine.
They're just chilling over there.
They're so far.
What is this?
There's something going on down here, man.
There's like a pod in the floor.
Oh, it's like an airdrop.
So it's gonna have like good material in it.
Oh, I see.
They're fighting to my left.
I see them on the roof.
Everybody in your team is dead?
Is your team just out?
Um, if everyone's got no lives, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Um, but you can actually resurrect teammates if they run out of lives.
Yeah, yeah.
Did she not do that?
Yeah, I did that.
I did that.
Oh, yeah.
You can do that.
They're all in there, but the pod... the C is over here, though.
I think they're just like bumping into each other and like tunneling on trying to kill each other.
Biocore C is 50% complete.
Hope they don't come near me.
I don't see nobody.
Dude, I am straight up doo-doo butter.
Oh, no.
On me.
Coming, coming, coming, coming.
Oh, cracked.
He's inside?
Alright.
Are you guys okay?
Because I'm looking at this other team right now.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
It's Kuzai.
Got a heal in it.
Oh, he's so fucking weak right now.
Get him.
I'm guarding the roofs.
I'm coming for you, bitch!
Ah!
He's... I...
Oh, shit.
He's got more shells.
Fuck.
Oh!
Oh, I got him.
Get... Fuck, Kuzai!
Go back to the fucking lobby, you bitch!
I have people... below me.
Oh, I have the Biocore.
I'm covering.
Sit, sit, sit.
I'm covering you over here.
I don't see nobody right now.
See, I'm going that way.
Yeah, I saw like a team here, but I don't see them right now.
Oh, there they are.
Oh, shit.
The reload.
No, no.
Oh,
they're on.
Sniper douchebag.
Come on!
Sniper off!
He's sniper.
Over me, dudes.
Wait, he...
He don't got that nog on him.
Wait, he left.
The sniper fight.
Why did you leave the sniper fight?
You fucking cowards!
Look, he ran away!
Chase him down, chase him down, I believe.
Wait, there's falloff?
Oh shit.
Okay, now I'm dead.
I need to run.
Wait, is there falloff?
Yeah, yeah, there's drop- Noooo!
Yeah, there's bullet drop.
Noooo!
You should remove that.
That's my- That's my honest- So, no, no, no, no.
Hear me out.
You can make a sniper that doesn't have any drop-off.
Oh, wait, how come this gun doesn't- How come this gun has drop-off?
I'm sorry, Doki, I can't- I can't bend the fucking knee!
What?
I can't give you anything!
You're a dumb!
You said this was a cheat code!
I gave you a cheat code!
I've used everything in my power to build that motherfucker!
And you're like- He has to give me more!
What more do you need?
No drop-off?
I just want one thing.
That's really it.
You just want the- I just want the moon!
Can you give me the moon?
Hey, I'm the invited guest.
There's people here.
Use my beautiful dev creation to kill this guy.
Yeah, yeah!
You're getting clapped in the cheeks!
Wait, wait, people are on you?
Oh shit, okay, I'm heading back.
Okay, I'm like 200 meters away.
I'll be there soon.
Soon?
I'm 200 meters away.
I'll be there.
Wait, how is there people there?
They walked there!
They used their legs!
That's not a thing.
I got it, I got it, I got it!
I'm coming over.
I'm almost there.
I'm 100 meters- I'm 170 meters.
I killed everyone, let's fucking go!
Let's go!
Guys, I'm almost- don't worry, 135.
See, WK just enabled them cheats, don't worry about it.
Yeah, see?
See?
If Ico can do it, like, I don't understand why.
This other dev, cool.
One of them?
Oh, hey.
Oh, he's scared.
There's a guy near me.
But he ran.
Oh, he's up here?
Got him.
Nice.
How are you still- okay, there you go.
Oh my god, it got me!
How are you still alive, bro?
Wait, I'm heading over.
We did it!
Did we win?
We were on fire.
Hell yeah, we did.
Yeah, you know what?
We didn't win, no thanks to my shitty sniper rifle, apparently.
Yeah, I mean, that's why I had my sniper rifle.
That is my sniper rifle!
No, it's in my hands.
I don't know about that.
It is in my hands.
Oh, god, dude.
This whole stream- this whole play to do this is an absolute whiplash.
I made this.
Do you have the do not return list, Iko?
Huh?
Do you have the do not return list?
Yeah, I'll put Doki and Big Ball Lettuce right along the top.
Oh, shit.
Iko, you didn't kill me without going down.
Get owned.
Did I win?
I don't know, did you?
I don't buy a dungeon, do I?
I don't buy a dungeon.
It's too late.
I already got in on the first day.
It's too late already.
Guys!
Look at me!
I got more damage than the dev!
Iko, you got downed by Connie's Nightmare, okay?
So...
By what?
Look at me!
Connie's Nightmare.
It's the name of the gun.
Is that what it's called?
That's what it's called.
It's Connie's Nightmare.
Connie's Nightmare was me getting my hands on fire stuff.
No, that's not her Nightmare.
I know what her Nightmare is.
It's Hydration.
Because she never fucking hydrates.
No, it's Rocky.
Or whatever you lot call Rocky.
Vegetable stuff.
She told me.
After I told her it was me, she left for my Nightmare.
What do you mean, sir?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, Doki, did you not die?
No!
She didn't die once, no!
I was a gamer.
Hella gaming.
Yeah!
She had the power of...
I had, like, double Jedi's damage, too.
Showed anime and friendship.
So, GG's, everybody.
We're closing this motherfrigger off.
Thank you, everybody, for joining us today.
I hope y'all had just as much fun as I did.
Every single one of you.
But you had fun?
Yeah, I had so much fun.
See, guys?
He had fun!
I'm clenching my fist so hard right now.
Guys, I told you!
He had fun!
No, it really was fun.
Thank you so much, everybody.
This is a really big blast.
I hope everybody here...
What the fuck is... What the fu... I'm seeing some crazy shit right now on my screen.
See, guys?
He had fun!
Sorry about that.
Little ADHD moment.
But, so, things I want to quickly close out on is...
One, tomorrow is our technical... our closed technical test.
Anyone is welcome to join it.
There is a registration process to it.
As you can join the technical test tomorrow.
So, if you want to play the most recent version of Ascendant, which was quite literally finalized today...
Yeah, that's locked out from DevHack Hacking.
You're more than welcome to register for that, and you will get access to the game tomorrow.
And this includes anyone's community in here.
If you want to bring friends in, if you want to bring your community in, you're more than welcome to.
It's closed.
It's closed, but the reason why we're calling it closed is because if we get too much people in here, people are going to be like, this game's dick.
Oh, shit.
It's closed.
Okay.
So, we're looking for feedback.
We're looking to make things better for the game and for the community when we get closer to launch.
So, you're welcome to try it out tomorrow.
Big changes are happening.
So, second is we have a lot more stuff coming along the way in terms of events.
We do these things every week, and anyone's more than welcome to come back.
We'll happily pull you back in.
See?
Anybody is welcome.
It's more than welcome to come back.
I'm not blacklisted.
If I was, he'd be like, accept no key.
I can't name everybody here, but for the most part, everyone here is a community member that supports these events like this.
So, if you want to try and, you know, take part in it, have some more fun, get to learn the game a little bit more, more than welcome to join us.
So, other than that, we have more events coming up, especially in the very, very close future.
I mentioned it earlier, but we're looking at ways that we can get more creator in.
We're looking at ways that we can get more events developed for the game.
So, think creator clans.
Think leaderboards for clans for those creators specifically.
Except in the fine print.
Except no key.
We're looking to see how we can get more of you into the game as well.
So, other than that, I have nothing else.
I know you had some more conversational stuff that you wanted to talk about, Metsu, so I'll stick around a little bit more.
But everybody else, the server should be up for, I think, the next 30 minutes.
So, you're more than welcome to hang around the lobby, play with some stuff, build a weapon out or two, test it out in 1v1 challenges.
You can do all of that.
And, yeah, other than that, thank you so much, everybody.
It really means a lot to us.
A hundred wins?!
Who the fuck is in this lobby?!
We won, though.
We won.
I had the main dev on my team.
Don't worry about the secret Raccoon devs.
That's a secret.
Oh, what?
There's a secret?
What?
Don't worry about it.
There's a secret?
Oh my god, I don't...
Guys, I got placed in the best team, guys.
Even with, like, a hundred wins.
Oh, I remember, so the last thing that we were talking about was...
Wait, is this over?
Like, the...
Oh, she's a dragon!
I don't understand, like, what was the victory aspect, because there's no...
For example, in Battle Royale's...
Guys, we won.
...traditional last-minute...
They might have a hundred wins, but we won.
...extraction shooters is that there's no real victory other than...
We won, guys.
...grabbing the shit that you want and leaving, right?
So with this, it being presented as Capture the Flag...
What is that?!
It's equivalent to Capture the Flag, but the...
How can I put it?
Why is this interacting?
Like, there's no, like, actual, like, victory...
Oh, what the fuck is that?!
...status thing.
That was kind of, like, throwing me off, because I'm trying to play in the sense of...
I can't even get there!
I'm just opening the door!
...all of us are competing to have, like, a victory screen, when in reality, we're just all competing to...
Like, I can't even get there, I'm just opening the door.
...get the only course that I can grab.
It's a door that I cannot reach.
But yeah, with ranked, I was thinking about...
Can I... I don't know if I... I need to listen to this.
...with the different tiers that you were talking about, if... within, like, a specific...
The Elevator.
The Elevator?
No, I can't reach down there.
I wouldn't know how to put it off, because if a team is just going ham and getting three cores, right?
But it's a big door!
Another team that isn't as good, when that other team gets off, even if they get one...
Look at that big door that we can't reach!
...everybody's eventually gonna hit, say, if, you know, it's, like, 50 cores for the day.
So I was just trying to figure out, like...
I guess we'll call it here.
How could you get around that?
I don't know, everybody is still here.
It's kind of... I don't want to make any comparisons and say that this is exactly how it's going to work.
But...
Right, right.
I think a good...
I feel weird.
Everybody is still here.
I want to say...
A very, very different game, right?
But the way that their ranking works is all about performance within those specific roles that you have.
Now, there's no roles in here, but...
What's Q&A?
Guys, what kind of questions do you guys have?
Wait!
Is this...
No!
...any game that we play in today.
So you're gonna have your ranked tiers...
Sorry, just really quickly, Jade.
Yeah, what's up?
If you guys have places to be created, don't worry about it.
You don't have to stick around.
I can just see chat.
Talking about DokiMiki.
It's okay.
We're just chatting now.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Guys, we can leave.
Don't worry about it!
We have permission to leave!
Anyway...
The test is over, don't worry.
Okay, okay.
So...
Yeah, the way that's gonna work is that you...
The way that's gonna work is that you...
No, this L-Painting can only go up!
Your performance is going to matter in every single game that you play.
So, rank...
This can only go up!
Just because you grabbed Bio 4...
But you've got zero overall score.
Like, you didn't really contribute to the team.
You did get a Bio Core.
You are walking out with a Bio Core, even in that rank match.
I contributed.
But you're not...
Are we legally allowed to leave the class now?
Professor, it's...
Class...
Class is supposed to end at 3.
Are we legally allowed to leave?
Or do we have to stick for the Q&A?
Can you ask if they can make the elevators go down?
I would say the only thing that's gonna...
Probably be hated, but what we do want to try is allowing mixed ranks.
Okay, we're just gonna leave the class, I guess, now.
...within these matches.
I don't know!
I don't know if you guys had any questions.
I didn't have any questions.
It's just...
It's a technical test.
Like, as long as the game is fun, that's all I care about.
Like...
I just...
As long as the game is fun.
And if the game's fun, that's all I care about.
It was technical stuff, so I was like, well, they were talking about matchmaking.
I mean, it's a technical test.
I'm pretty sure there's going to be other updates and stuff going on, too.
Oh yeah, by the way, guys.
By the way, for those who were not a member goon, I'm having some new updates for you guys to show you guys.
Watch this.
So as you guys all know, I have glasses now.
Yeah.
But like, what I didn't show you guys for the public streams was...
So yeah, like, that's what I...
So this is like a new update on the skin suit, so I can easily go.
Wait, maybe I have a green screen.
Okay.
Sorry, my magenta screen.
So I have that now.
And also, if you guys didn't know, you might have seen this.
You might have seen this before.
But basically, when my...
The tomato is out of the skin suit, this is what happens.
So yeah, like...
So, you know, if I have to use the bathroom or anything...
If I have to use the bathroom and I, you know, the tomato is out of the suit...
I can use the bathroom instead.
So it's loading...
We're loading right now.
Um...
But yeah, anyway, those are the updates.
I was gonna show you guys the updates in the beginning of the stream but then I didn't do my homework going in.
I hope they...
I hope the devs still have fun with me.
I was so unprepared, I...
I literally...
They were like, here's the key to the game.
And I was like, sweet.
And then just show up at like 6 p.m.
And I was like, okay.
I didn't realize.
I was like, I had...
There's homework?
But yeah, thank you to the devs for inviting me.
And for letting me try Ascendant.
It was pretty fun.
I had a really great time getting cheat codes from the devs too.
Thoughts on the movement?
I feel like...
There was...
I think the slide definitely needs a little bit of work.
I don't know if it was ping.
I don't know what server it was.
I didn't know...
I didn't know like what server we were on.
What region it was.
But it did feel...
The movement feels just a little bit stiff.
Because I was...
I don't know if you guys saw it.
But at some moments like...
I don't know if it's the slide or it was my ping.
But yeah.
Also like...
The fact that like...
Oh my god.
Like when you have like an actual overpowered gun in your hands.
The other guns like just doesn't compare.
Because I was like wondering.
I was like why does my sniper do...
I was like wondering why does my guns do so little damage compared to like other people's guns.
And then I realized.
Oh they had custom guns.
Like I was like...
I was like there's no way.
I was like how...
Is there shots hitting me more?
Yeah.
I was like...
And I was like...
Oh it's the fucking custom guns.
Like the crafted guns.
And they had like so much time in the game.
So they obviously they have crafted guns.
So the moment...
The moment I got a real gun.
Like the moment I had a real gun in my hands.
I was like it's over for you guys.
It's fucking over.
I was like...
You're going...
Yeah it's over.
You're going down.
I have a fucking crafted gun.
I didn't like...
The one thing I really didn't like though was...
You can't swap your gun when you're reloading.
I don't know.
I don't know if I fucked it up.
But like when I was doing that 1v1 against that other guy.
And I tried to swap to my pistol.
I was reloading my shotgun.
And I had to wait until my shotgun finished reloading.
And then swap to the pistol.
Like I don't know if I had to cancel.
I think maybe I had to melee cancel.
But like...
I would definitely like to swap my gun.
If I want to like...
I don't want to cancel my reloading by just swapping my gun.
But I might have had to melee cancel.
I'm not used to...
I'm not used to like...
Swap...
Melee cancel the swap.
But yeah like...
That was the one thing I really didn't like.
I was locked into the reload animation.
Because I was trying to like...
Because I just realized...
Oh I should swap my pistol.
But I already reloaded my shotgun.
But other than that it was really fun.
Learning the mechanics.
Because it was like...
It was basically capture the flag.
And then the environment stuff.
The snail...
The environment stuff.
So...
It was pretty fun.
Having the devs teach me how to play.
Also fucking...
Okay...
The tank was so cool.
But the fact that like...
I got stopped.
Stopped by the fucking tunnel.
Because it's like...
This parking lot can only take cars that are 4 feet...
4.5 feet and under.
I was like...
No!
Where is...
The realism.
I can't believe it.
I was like...
The fucking tank.
Why tank?
If I can't go anywhere.
Exactly!
Why can't I use the tank if I can't go anywhere?
I was so surprised.
I was like...
Why can't my tank go anywhere?
It looked cool.
I'm just sad I couldn't do anything.
I can't even run over the trees.
I can't even burn the trees down.
What is the point?
I like the soundtrack though.
I like that.
I was just...
I was like...
Wow!
They got the final countdown right.
So I was like...
Very impressed.
They got right to the final countdown.
And now...
And now the creators of the final countdown are gonna get my ad revenue.
But that's okay.
That's...
They clearly need more money.
But I had a great time.
Huge shoutout to the developers for inviting me and for...
And for giving me a code.
I'm sorry I didn't do my homework.
My dog ate my homework.
I'm really sorry.
I did my homework like five minutes before class started.
But at least I showed up.
You know?
Unlike that other guy that never showed up.
Unlike that one guy that didn't show up.
I showed up.
Alright, I gotta go.
Um...
Yeah.
Anyways.
I win it.
Like, I wasn't gonna stream today.
But like I said.
I got an invite to this playtest.
So that's why I'm here.
And, uh, I hope you guys had a great time watching.
Um...
By the way, also a little update.
Also a little update, by the way.
We picked the winners for the Gamersub art contest.
Finally.
I'm so sorry.
I got really delayed because life.
But we finally picked the winners.
We have contacted the winners of the Gamersubs art contest.
We sent emails out, I believe, yesterday.
Those that got top...
Those that got...
Actually, okay.
I think...
Oh, okay.
Wait, I need to remember what my staff told me.
Okay, so, top 5 got emails currently.
Because we are going to be using the top 5 for merch.
So, top 5 got emails.
The other placements, top 6 and under, like 6 to 22, have not yet got emails yet.
So, if you're top 5, you got your emails.
Because we're planning on, you know, making merch out of it.
So, just that.
So, you guys didn't get email, but you're in the top 22.
I don't know if emails are being sent out later.
I'm not handling the email.
I chose... I just chose who won.
That's...
I chose the top 22.
That's it.
And then I let the staff and gamer subs handle the rest.
So, I most likely will be announcing the winners next week.
So, yeah.
Anyway, also Minecraft.
For those who are wondering about the Minecraft server.
So, apparently, I was...
I mean, the members, I was talking about...
Sorry about the whitelist.
The whitelist has been, like, stopped for a while.
Because we're trying to deal with making a special Discord server.
Just for the Minecraft.
And it's not gonna be...
I thought it was gonna be done today.
For the Discord server.
For the whitelist.
But they contacted me today.
And saying that the main developer.
The main person that's implementing it.
Has to go on a trip.
A business trip for the next two weeks.
So, he said that, like...
Well, the other developers will be working on implementing other updates.
To the server.
Minecraft server.
But the guy that's gonna implement it on Discord.
The main developer for the Discord.
He's gonna go on a business trip.
So...
And he's like, when he comes back.
It'll be implemented on the Discord server.
So, that is why.
It's not...
Yesterday, on the membership stream.
I said it might be done today.
But, like, apparently...
Apparently...
The other...
He has to go on a business trip.
So...
So, he won't be there until two weeks.
So, that's why.
Sorry for those who are waiting for the whitelist.
Whitelist has literally been stopped for a while now.
Because we had to implement the new updates into the server.
So, we haven't been able to add anything.
And I was very busy with a lot of stuff.
So...
But...
Life is going on track at the moment.
I'm a lot less...
No, I'm still really busy.
But can finally handle, like, behind the scenes work now.
Like...
Properly.
So, yeah.
Life is on track.
Like, it's still being fixed.
But life is on track.
Anyway.
I had a great time.
I really did.
I had a great time hanging out with everybody.
And...
Like I said.
Like, I went...
I didn't realize.
I legitimately...
I thought...
That, like...
I didn't realize it was, like, a playtest with a very small group of people.
Because when they said...
I thought it was gonna be, like...
Like, I wasn't...
I've been in Apex playtest.
And I've been, like, another, like, big...
Like, I guess, like, Apex playtest.
And...
Marvel Rivals.
So, I legitimately assumed, like, it was just people just queuing up.
Queuing up.
And then we're just playing.
I didn't realize that it was a very small...
Like, group of people.
So, I went in very chill.
Like, I went...
Like, I went in thinking that I was...
Like, I was just gonna...
I could, like, talk to you guys before going in and start...
Like, talk to you guys before play...
Like, just queuing up a game.
But I was, like, oh, man.
This is a very personal experience.
I was, like...
I didn't even realize, like, you know...
Devs were gonna be talking to me.
Like...
Um...
So, yeah.
So, that's why I went...
When the beginning of the stream, I was like...
I don't even know...
I don't even know if I was suppo- I was like, oh, no.
Am I allowed to stream this, like, discord call?
It was like, at the playtesters, we need you in the lobby in the voice chat while we prepare.
And I was like, what?
I was like, what do you mean you need me in the discord call?
So, I was just gonna talk to my chat at 6 p.m.
I was like, oh, man.
I was like, what?
And then they had my stream open and it was like, Doki is asking right now if we could stream this discord conversation, and I was like, NO!
WHAT?!
What do you mean you're watching this?!
This is my private sanctuary in front of 2,000 people!
How did you know?
This is my 2,000 plus echo chamber.
Very private.
I thought it was really funny.
I thought that was really funny.
I got called out so many times.
They're like, Doki, did you do the tutorial?
And I'm like, YEAH!
As I am in the custom character.
I was customizing my character.
Anyway, that was fun.
It was really fun.
And guys, I'm going to call it here.
Tomorrow is another sponsored stream.
This one was just an invited playtest.
I wasn't sponsored.
I wasn't sponsored to do today's stream, but I wanted to do the playtest and check it out.
I heard stuff about Sen and so I thought it was fun to check it out.
Tomorrow is an actual sponsored stream.
Bandai sponsored me to check out one of their newest games, Senuality.
I'm pronouncing it wrong because I'm illiterate.
But yeah, go support that stream tomorrow.
Creator Corner, thank you so much for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can't describe this so much without putting in words.
I guess thank you so much for your love and your support of your community.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat, Creator Corner.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Anyway, I'm going to see you guys tomorrow, everybody.
Thanks for hanging out.
The rest of the week has been great.
I haven't been working.
The first three days.
By the way, I did show up in a couple of collabs with Ellum because he invited me to some collabs while I was resting.
I didn't really announce it, but you can check out Ellum.
I know Nycewig was in one of the collabs and stuff.
Ellum and Nycewig's mods.
Because I didn't announce it on Twitter or social media because I was also resting.
And then it's one of those games where...
It's basically like...
Where's Doki?
Like...
Where's Waldo?
And Psychonauts.
So I didn't announce it because I was super down low key.
Not like low energy, but not streaming.
So then I was just like, I'll just fucking exist.
Interact when I need to interact type deal.
And I know people would be trying to find like, oh, where's DokiBrain in the POVs?
Because I was jumping around.
Like just hanging out and stuff.
So yeah.
That's why I tend to not announce these types of collabs.
Especially if I don't have my own POV.
And there's a lot of people in it.
If there's a lot of people in it, I tend to not announce it.
Especially if I have no POV.
So yeah.
There's that.
If you guys want to check out some VODs to catch up on if you want to.
Anyway.
I am...
I'm going to head out for real now, chat.
It's been a very nice rest week.
Not going to lie.
I really needed it.
I definitely really, really needed the rest week.
It was really nice.
Just not doing anything and just sleeping in.
Yesterday I started working again.
So back on work mode.
But other than that, it's been a nice break.
I almost got really burnt out after Street Fighter.
I play so much Street Fighter.
That I was so burnt out.
Because I did not take a lot of breaks.
Other than...
I'm glad I did take the break the day before the finals.
But at that point, I was like, I needed to rest.
I was like, I needed to rest.
So it's been really nice.
It's been really, really nice just being able to relax.
I feel...
I know...
Especially like...
I know like the team...
Because the teams...
You guys don't know.
Sykuno will be representing me for Team Brian F.
So Sykuno will be substituting for me for the tournament.
So everybody is grinding every day on Street Fighter.
For those who are...
He's going to be wearing a Doki Bird wig.
That was my only condition.
I was like...
Um...
That's why I tweeted out.
I was like, I need a wig.
I was like...
They were like asking my...
Is it okay if Sykuno subs in?
And I was like...
If he wears the wig.
That's literally it!
I was like...
Only if he wears the wig.
And they're like...
Okay...
Like we can make that happen.
Because I was like...
I'll pay for it.
I was like...
I'll pay for the wig.
I just need him to wear it.
Like...
I was like...
So he's going to wear the wings.
I've commissioned somebody.
It's going to be done by TwitchCon.
But yeah, I was like, everybody is grinding Street Fighter right now.
I know Lily got to plat rank, as in the beginner division too.
She's in plat rank and everybody is literally playing every day on Street Fighter.
I was like, Godspeed to all of you guys.
To everybody grinding every day for it.
Because I was like, oh my God, I don't know if I could...
I don't know.
Because I'm a variety streamer.
I'm a variety streamer, so I was like, I don't know.
If I was at TwitchCon, I had to play Street Fighter for another two weeks until TwitchCon.
And then hard grind the game.
And I was like, oh my God, I don't know.
So I wish them good luck in all the division.
Yeah, I wish them good luck.
I know like Bra Pro went on vacation right after.
Because like he got like burnt out from the rank grind like the day before the finals too.
So I was like, you got to be able to balance it too.
So I hope everybody will be okay.
I know SK has been fucking streaming Street Fighter for like eight plus hours every day.
Like I was like, oh my God.
Like, are you okay?
Because she's like, til queuing rank two.
And I'm like, are you?
Oh my God, SK.
Like she's been doing eight plus hours til queuing Street Fighter rank every day.
And I'm just like, are you okay?
I told you guys, I was like, I told you guys, I stopped rank at silver four because it's never been that angry before.
This has been like, I had like, I've never had experience in rank where I've been that angry that I literally stopped playing rank.
Because I'm very competitive.
I'm a very competitive person in general.
So like I could queue rank for like a long time.
But like...
I hit a breaking point with Street Fighter rank.
I actually did.
Like I actually...
That I stopped.
Like I was just like, I'm just doing custom rooms.
Like I'm doing custom rooms.
I've never like been so mad.
I've never been so mad.
I was like, no I can't.
I can't keep doing rank anymore.
I'm just gonna practice custom.
Practice against viewers.
But it was still a really fun experience.
Especially like interacting with...
It was really fun though.
I made a lot of new friends.
In Sajam Slam.
In Street Fighter.
I made a lot of new friends.
And got to interact with a lot of new people.
And a lot of people seemed to really like watching me too.
From the FGC community.
So I still don't know what Doki Zeme means.
Everybody keeps saying like, oh my god Doki Zeme.
I don't know what that means.
And I still don't know what neutral means.
But I'm pretending that I do.
I'm not.
I'm gonna let everybody think I actually understand what neutral is.
I still don't know what it actually means.
But I'm glad people enjoyed my...
I was...
I said it in my member stream.
But I was basically everybody's character arc.
Which was funny.
I thought that was really funny.
That I suddenly became everybody's character arc.
Like I was like...
Like...
Like I helped grow everybody in general.
Like everybody had like a storyline with me.
The amount of like clips that showed up.
Like every action of finally beating Doki Bird.
Like from different people that I fought.
Like I thought that was really funny.
Um...
So...
Yeah.
I was...
I was everybody's character arc.
Everybody...
Like every tournament needed a heal.
And I'm glad to be that heal.
And I'm glad everybody enjoyed my dumb ass...
Me.
Like...
Enjoyed this dumb ass.
I don't know what I was doing.
But I'm glad people had a great time watching.
Uh...
So yeah.
Thank you to all the new viewers.
That followed me.
And subscribed to me.
After Sajam Slam.
Um...
Yeah!
And then I got acknowledged by Angry Bird.
If you guys didn't...
Wait.
Is it Angry Bird or Big Bird?
I got...
I lost track of all the birds.
I lost...
I lost track of the birds.
Sorry.
I got acknowledged by Big Bird.
As part of the bird family.
Um...
The third...
Bird.
I got acknowledged by Big Bird.
Um...
There's too many birds.
It's me, Angry Bird, and Big Bird.
And he like acknowledged me.
And was like...
Yes, you're part of the bird family now.
And I'm like...
That's me!
I'm part of the bird family.
Uh...
So yeah.
He acknowledged me.
Um...
So I thought that was really cool.
I...
I thought...
Yeah!
A lot of the FGC...
Uh...
Pros...
Acknowledged me.
And I thought that was really cool.
Like a lot of people were freaking out...
About it.
Uh...
And like...
Even Justin was like...
It was so fun.
Like...
I'm like watching you play.
And...
He was really sad.
That I wasn't gonna be at TwitchCon.
Uh...
Playing...
I wasn't gonna...
Be playing at TwitchCon.
For...
Uh...
My team.
And he was like...
No!
I'm gonna...
We're gonna miss out on a Doki Zeme.
Like he like...
Met the enemy about it.
And I was like...
I'm sorry.
And he was like...
You're so fun to play with.
And you're so fun to watch.
I was like...
Thank you.
I really appreciate it, Justin.
I really appreciate it.
Um...
But yeah.
It was really nice.
Um...
But yeah.
Great experience.
Overall.
Um...
Uh...
Thank you to Seijam for inviting me.
For...
Well...
For accepting me.
I applied.
Okay.
Haha!
Uh...
For accepting me.
Um...
Again...
Uh...
For...
Street Fighter.
Seijam Slam.
Um...
I'm glad that a lot of people enjoyed...
Uh...
Enjoyed my moments there.
And...
Um...
Enjoyed watching me.
It was great.
Anyway.
I'm gonna...
Say bye for real now.
Cause...
Uh...
I need a rest, I guess.
Haha!
I need to eat dinner.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me...
Head to bed!
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!